Miss Dyer would you hide a certain thing
right yes where no one can see them
thank you
okay what's this committee called oh you
have a special committee
call to order meeting of the special
committee on the Family Division of the
Circuit Court of the State of New
Hampshire
and we are privileged in having several
members of the circuit court with us
today
just a reminder to those in the audience
that this is not a hearing whereby
members can ask to testify this is a
work session for the committee whereby
we can have input from in this case the
Judiciary
to inform us as to what we might
recommend back or even submit lsrs for
future legislation so we're very glad to
have members of the audience and welcome
you to sit silently and listen
I'd like to invite up
um judge king and anyone you wish to
bring we can get more tables and mics if
you wish
red is go
okay thank you good morning
yeah like I have the gavel that it's all
backwards yeah
well you need that
okay
well good morning Mr chairman Madam Vice
chair and members of this committee
thank you very much for the opportunity
to be here this morning
um my fellow judges can introduce
themselves when they speak but just for
the record my name is David King I'm the
administrative judge of the circuit
court and I have with me this morning
Judge Jennifer Lemire who sits in
Brentwood judge Susan Ashley who's my
fellow administrative judge who sits in
Rochester also and
judge Michael mace who sits in Franklin
as well as arrogant Aaron kriegen who
you know is our general counsel
my understanding is therefore General
categories that you want us to cover
this morning training
gal slash parenting coordinators forms
and the rules of evidence and if it's
okay with the chair I'd just like to
make some preliminary remarks and then
we can dive into the details
first of all I want to thank you for all
of the work that you've put in over the
past many months
I know you've learned a lot about what
the Circuit Court Family Division does
and particularly your focus on parenting
and marital cases and you've taken a lot
of time to hear from many people over
the last few months and I know you
worked over the summer as well and we're
very grateful for the time you've spent
I was especially pleased that every
member of the committee took an
opportunity to visit one of our courts
last spring and I hope that was
educational and I hope you got a chance
to see how the Family Division operates
in a real day in real time and got to
meet some of the staff and see what
happens behind the scenes
I'm sure and I haven't had a chance
obviously to be here for your hearings
or to watch them remotely but I'm sure
you've heard from a lot of people who
are unhappy with the Family Division and
that's that's not a surprise to me and
as I was thinking over the weekend about
coming here this morning I thought back
to my own career that started almost 40
years ago and I did a fair amount of
marital work in my early days as a
lawyer
and back then we appeared in the
Superior Courts there was no mediation
so either you settled your case or you
tried it in front of a superior court
judge or if you were lucky in front of a
marital master
and I would work hard to prepare those
cases and do my exhibits and my requests
for rulings and get the decision from
the judge and even when I thought it was
a good decision most often my client was
unhappy and so after a few years of
doing that I it wasn't very satisfying
work because I realized
there's no making clients happy in the
marital business so this idea of having
unhappy litigants from the divorce world
is certainly nothing it's not a new
phenomenon
I'd like to talk real briefly about the
resources in the Family Division because
we've just released our 2024 schedule
and not here to ask for resources I know
this is not the forum for that but I
think the numbers are instructive to
explain
uh some of the complaints that you've
probably heard about cases not getting
heard fast enough or order is not
getting out quick enough
people wishing they had more time for
their temporary hearings and things like
that and as you consider legislation
which could impose new deadlines this
obviously is a factor too so we schedule
as I think you've all heard me say
before based on the weighted caseload
it's a statutory scheme that the
legislature created and for 2024 the
statutory need based on weighted
caseload is 13 303 days of Judge time
across the state for all divisions
that's all in with every every case that
we need to hear may I interrupt you to
ask with the addition of six judges has
this gone up now or is this still a work
in process so Mr chairman that number is
irregardless of how many judges we have
that this is how many we need
what we have my next point I think will
hopefully be a list illustrative on that
we have currently 40 let's see 41
full-time judges we swore one in last
Friday we're swearing another one in
Thursday that gets us to 42 with all of
our full-time judges our part-time
judges our judicial referees which are
we have 13 judges now over the age of 70
who are currently hearing cases
they give us as many days as they will
or are allowed to give us all in with
everybody we have 10
916 days to give so we're short almost
2400 days
next year 22 calendar year 2024 which
equates to about nine and a half judges
we have just to answer your question Mr
Jim we have uh one judge who's currently
awaiting a public hearing next week
we have two unfilled vacancies that the
governor is has yet to fill and then in
the next fiscal year starting July 1st
there are four more positions so if all
of those are filled we'll be at 49
judges and I think we'll still be sure
but we'll be in good shape but we have
at least four known retirements next
year too so it's kind of a
revolving door in the circuit court and
obviously as judges come on board they
have to be trained and brought up to
speed which we'll talk about training in
a bit
because so many of our cases involve
statutory deadlines however and abuse
neglect cases guardianships termination
of parental rights landlord tenant those
cases have to get priority on our
dockets and where there's Flex it comes
from the Civil dockets the small claims
in civil cases and the divorce cases so
when we need to carve out time on the
docket for to meet those statutory
deadlines it's those cases the divorces
the small claims the civil cases that
have to get pushed out a bit
another data point I'd like you to
consider is that we get about 7 000 new
marital and parenting cases a year and
we get another fourth more than four
thousand reopened
family cases a year so add those
together that's the docket for the
Family Division and the marital
parenting Arena
as you know 85 percent of our litigants
are self-represented we don't have court
monitors you've heard concerns about the
record in the Superior Court there's a
court monitor that sits at the recording
equipment all day long to make sure it's
working properly and the microphones are
working and all that so when we've had
instances where there are problems with
the record
chances are the judge turned the
recording on or the court security
officer turned the recording on and
there's no one to monitor that during
the day and and as you know we don't
have lock lurks so we have three staff
attorneys two today because one just
left
um our judges write their own orders law
clerks would certainly allow our judges
to write more complete and timely orders
but the data point that I think is
really important for you to consider is
seven thousand cases for four to five
thousand reopened cases in 2021 which is
the most recent data I could get from
the Supreme Court there were 20 appeals
from final divorce orders two zero
twenty and there were another 42
discretionary appeals for other marital
issues which would be parenting child
support post-divorce cases
so a tiny fraction of the cases that our
judges hear like way less than one
percent actually get appealed and that's
where if there's a concern with a
judge's order or what evidence got in
that shouldn't that's where those issues
get sorted out so I think that's a data
point that tells you that by and large
overall the judges in the Circuit Court
Family Division are doing a great job I
mean less than one percent get appealed
I think that's a pretty important data
point
and you've certainly heard about a lot
of cases that get drawn out for years
you perhaps in the courts you were able
to see some of the files of those cases
that have gone on that take up you know
reams of paper
in 2014 we took a deep dive to look at
our time to disposition
we found that there are two common
threads that tend to make a case get
long and drawn out one are complicated
divorces with lots of assets where there
are closely held corporations and maybe
a lot of experts but more importantly
it's cases that involve disputes over
parental decision making and residential
responsibility that can cause a case to
go on for several years
that said most of the divorce cases in
the Circuit Court resolve quite quickly
about 50 percent close within three
months
70 percent within six months eighty
percent are closed within nine months
and 87 percent are closed within 12
months
and of course those that drag on for
years take up a lot of resources and
slow down the process for the the cases
that would otherwise resolve more
quickly so bottom line I'm really proud
of the work that our judges and staff
are doing
that said we know we can always do
better we look forward to working
collaboratively with this group and
talking about whatever legislative
efforts you want to consider that will
make the process
go more smoothly so I
unless you want to ask questions now we
can get into the sort of four categories
I'd like to give the special committee a
chance to jump in at various times chair
recognizes the vice chair for a question
the judges I had never focused in all
these years before on how
understaffed
the court is not so much with judges
you're understaffed
but with clerks I had no I personally
had no awareness
that that judges in the Circuit Court
did not have clerks and other kinds of
administrative staff
and
I guess I I'm kind of speechless I'm
shocked about it as I see it all I see
the effort you've made to try to use
Electronics to handle certain things but
no staff to assist the citizens who need
guidance and how to use that equipment
for example
if you were to have
an opportunity
to bring more people in
would your first choice be to bring in
more judges or would it be to bring in
more staff I think I think that's an
easy question it would be to bring in
more staff and that was our pitch to the
legislative
finance committee this year and actually
they were very good to us they gave us
31 new staff positions in the Circuit
Court which is enough to do what we need
to do the problem is as I sit here today
we have about 40 vacant positions that
were vacant
before the new budget kicked in
we very much want to fill those
positions first because those sort of
run the gamut from the entry level
positions to mid-level positions and we
want to sort out our internal candidates
and get those experienced folks situated
before we open up the the doors to the
outside so to speak and then we have
those 31 positions so we have over 70
vacant staff positions today Statewide
in the Circuit Court which is we had to
close Candia for example because we had
zero staff in Candia we posted several
positions for the Candia Court we had no
applicants
so we moved the Family Division cases to
Dairy and we send a judge and staff
members to Dairy once a week to do the
criminal docket which there are venue
issues in criminal cases but we very
much need to fill the staff positions
that we have I think all of our clerks
would agree if we fill those positions
with folks who are trained because
there's a pretty steep learning curve
most of the people that come in the
courts don't know what a plaintiff or a
defendant is for example
they don't know how the Odyssey case
management system works but once they're
trained if those seats are filled we'll
be getting orders out timely the judges
will have staff to process their cases
we won't have court monitors which I I
mean I that's an expense that would be
up to this body to fund
I wanted Superior Court Judge goes on
the bench they have a court monitor they
have a probably have a law Clerk and
they probably have someone from the
clerk's office most likely a deputy
clerk who's a lawyer in the courtroom
with them our judges are often as you
probably saw on your field trip in the
courtroom Maybe by themselves or maybe
with a ca2
sitting to process paperwork but it's
it's a different concept with a a court
assistant an entry-level Court assistant
follow up if I could
I could just vacancies
and the reason we are we're told the
reason is because the salaries are too
low
um
and then combined with the need for
certain training or
why do you think that you have 40
vacancies now
I think it's a combination of factors
it's a competitive marketplace right now
to attract people we our number one
budget priority in this session which
the legislature funded was to raise the
labor grades for our entry level
positions we were at about 15 an hour
for starting wage and now we're closer
to 20. so that that is helping we're
seeing a little bit of a difference in
most areas of the state we're not losing
people to Dunkin Donuts and McDonald's
which we literally were before
as probably no surprise to this
committee though
the Millennials who are looking for jobs
don't care about health insurance
because either they're on their parents
health insurance or they're never going
to get sick they just want to know how
much am I going to get paid
by the hour what's my paycheck going to
be and I understand that so there are
other businesses that are paying more
hourly wages and don't have our benefits
we we're not competitive with them
and it's hard work
um you know we're paying these people
not a lot of money to get yelled at at
the window I I've told the story many
times but we were doing second
interviews in one of our courts and we
had the second interview candidates in
the lobby waiting to be called in for
the interview and there was a person at
the window in a Family Division case who
was screaming at a court assistant
because they were unhappy and one of our
candidates who I think was the leading
candidate got up and walked out and said
I can't work in this environment so it's
hard it's hard work and these are people
that are responsible to make sure that
arrest warrants are getting in the
system so if it's a warrant is vacated
somebody doesn't get arrested over the
weekend it's it's important intense
high-level work and we don't pay a lot
let me follow up to what you just said
was there no one in law enforcement of
immediately or quickly available to stop
this
breach of the Peace
um we
we don't I mean it
we don't engage certainly don't engage
law enforcement and the court security
officers are are not going to I mean
they make ask someone to to calm down
but it's it it's a daily it's a daily
thing in most of our courts it's just
the nature of the business
does it need to be with the police
presence
um
I don't know I I just
it's a I'm not sure if the police
presence is from time to time the police
do have to get involved if it gets
physical but I think the you know these
are emotional cases people have the
right to be emotional and unfortunately
our court staff are trained to try to
de-escalate uh we could we'll we're
working on that we're going to do a
training soon about de-escalation and
dealing with these situations both for
court security officers and for our
front line staff but it's it honestly Mr
chairman it's the nature of the it's the
nature of the Beast
um also to follow up on money did the 10
plus 2 percent raise that the
legislature amazingly agreed to in the
budget apply to uh Court Personnel yes
it did so it's not just the entry-level
position that got a bump it would be
other positions too that's true good
thank you
um
representative ball
thank you chairman Pearson and thank you
judge king for being here I'm just
wondering if there has ever been any
effort between the court system and the
Department of Education in trying to get
students perhaps who are not looking to
go on to college but perhaps want to do
an independent study or we offer
coursework in our high schools to try
and pull students who might be looking
for some type of a career in the law
system or in the courtroom or a
courthouse but not yet ready to move on
to college is there any ever been any
talk about doing that is a way of
bringing in more candidates yeah great
question representative well not
specifically with the Department of
Education we do send HR folks or HR
folks go to job fairs
um I've I've said I'll go to high
schools and try to recruit people myself
I mean it it can be a very rewarding
career we're about every year we do a
ceremony for our 25-year employees and
you'd be surprised how many folks stay
with us for a long time and get a career
out of it we have used summer interns we
had some this summer doing
you know more sort of routine processing
destroying old files things of that
nature we recruit interns and externs
from the law school we're fortunate to
have Franklin Pierce I'm going to call
it Franklin Pierce Law Center because
that's what it was called when I went
there UNH School of Law first and second
your students who who several spend the
summers in our courts with our judges
who they sort of work as quasi-law
clerks and it's a great opportunity for
them and it's helpful to the judges and
staff even some college students who are
thinking about a career in the law we
have no money to pay them but
we take them out for lunch once in a
while and and give them some exposure to
the court system and an opportunity to
network and it that that's proven to be
pretty beneficial
I will do Apollo
follow-up follow-up would it be
something
food in working with the doe to see if
we can establish some type of a of a
drawing system from the high schools to
offer entry-level positions and training
absolutely any feeding Network that we
can tap into to get
um applicants to come to the courts
would be
wide open as far as I'm concerned I'd be
happy to follow up on that thank you
very much
um judge king I am aware of a report
that was generated we were told that a
while ago saying how many more judges
are needed and the criteria for making
that recommendation I recollect had been
changed to something that was much more
realistic could you get us that report
as we're thinking not just thank you for
the new budget but the one coming up
pretty soon could we have copies of that
absolutely would you like an electronic
version would you like it in paper how
would you like it
it's about I don't know 90 Pages it's a
paper okay I'll make copies and I'll I
can send an electronic version too so
that you have the option the number is a
I think off the top of my head it's
rounded 65 judges is the need in the
Circuit Court we're fully loaded right
now 43. is there a cliff notes version
version of it uh there's an executive
summary that's I think what yes properly
called yes yes and I mean that was a
study that we started back in 2019 and
then this thing's called covid Hit And
we put the brakes on because we didn't
want to measure
the need during a pandemic so we
finished it up we actually restarted and
did it the only thing that I'll I'll say
to you when you review that and then and
the number it's a big number but bear in
mind that was a study where every single
judge and every staff member in both
Superior and circuit court kept detailed
logs every day for six weeks of
everything they did so I worked on a
criminal case for three minutes I mean
it was very detailed work
but we in the Circuit Court we measured
things the way we do them so a temporary
hearing was 30 minutes because it had to
be when I think the two judges behind me
that do this work would say we really
need an hour for temporary hearings we
just don't have an hour to give so we in
some ways we actually measured chaos but
the result is I think pretty
illustrative of the fact that we're
short
with the committee's consideration on
this would we like the 90-page report
sent electronically and the executive
summary sent both electronically and in
written form
yeah
sounds good if we could have that
of course thank you not a problem
any further questions representative
long
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you judge
uh I'm looking more for data also on
staff support
um I know the twenty dollars was
effective July 1st uh increase in the
starting salaries I I don't believe
because of the work I saw him doing that
twenty dollars is gonna cut it so I
don't know if you have
um
um some rollover uh you know how many
people how many people trained and
worked for six seven eight nine months a
year two years and left
um we do we we have some data on on
turnover I can tell you uh for example
in the information center which is where
all of our phone calls
um we just we started the information
center in 2012 we just took our 5
millionth call this summer
each in we call them agents each
information center agent takes about a
hundred calls a day a lot of those are
from unhappy people a lot of them are
are borderline threatening we've had
death threats against judges that come
in I mean they're it's a high high level
job we have about a 60 turnover in the
information center which means ever for
every 10 people you hire six leave
within 12 months and it's an intensive
training process to get those folks on
board the good thing about those jobs is
they're thanks to what we learned during
covet almost all of the agents work
remotely so uh the twenty dollars an
hour goes further because they don't
have gas expenses for example which is a
way to attract people into those
positions even though they're they're
intense positions we're hoping people
will tend to stay in those longer
because of the remote aspect of the work
and the increased wages but I agree
representative along the 20 bucks Keeps
Us sort of uh the executive branch all
got the 10 raise too right so we're not
stealing people from them we're trying
to steal people from law firms
looking collaterally where we can for
example advertise in a paralegal
brochure that goes to paralegals
Association to see if we can attract
some of those folks to the court system
for our benefits that law firms might
not be able to offer quick follow-up
follow-up thank you uh so is the data
accessible online or the HR data correct
no but I can get that for you all right
yeah I don't need name
how many employees what the rollover is
yes I don't know if you did exit
interviews we have done we do exit
interviews not in every single case but
typically there's an exit interview and
I just round numbers we have about 375
non-judicial employees in the circuit
court so 70 percent I'm sorry 70
employees is you know pretty close to 20
vacancy right now any further questions
on Staffing or pay or hoped for Staffing
um please continue okay then I think
it's time for you to hear from the
experts uh if you want to indulge I
would call Judge lemur up to talk about
gardening ad items and parenting
coordinators if that's I can do that in
a minute but before you go I was under
the impression that one of the reasons
Family Court was started so that someone
sitting in the courtroom who's very sad
it's a divorce situation there's a lot
of emotion it could be sitting next to
somebody who in a criminal trial and
they didn't think that that was very
good
um I may have been given false
information
not sure I understand the question Mr
chairman I'm sorry the question would be
if you've got people who they're going
to be hearings
um this is before Family Court started
you are in circuit court and the next
case may be more of a crime than the one
that was just a divorce first of all
need to know if that is a was a fact
so before there was a circuit court or
before there was a family division the
divorces were in Superior Court okay so
that would not be a fact then what I
just mentioned as a reason to carve out
Family Court no I think the reason the
Carvel Family Court I wish
representative Lynn was here because he
would agree with me the Superior Court
didn't want to do divorces anymore so
they were trying to figure out a way to
get rid of them they came up with the
idea of marital Masters which was a help
but judges were still doing them and so
the idea was to create the Family
Division which was a pilot project in
1996 in Rockingham County and in Grafton
County and it was I think the longest
pilot project in the history of the
court system but it went on for a long
time
eventually under the leadership of Chief
Justice delanis at rolled out we didn't
finish rolling it out until about two
years ago when we finally closed the
Plaistow Court that's when the Family
Division rollout was complete but the
idea was to the concept and it's in the
statute was to have one judge for one
family which we've talked about before
that sounds great in reality it's hard
to do for a variety of reasons
but the idea was to have
specialized judicial officers which
would be originally marital Masters who
were specially trained in marital cases
judge Lemire was a marital Master we had
a robust marital master program and then
the legislature as part of the Circuit
Court Bill House Bill 6 uh 629 I believe
in 2011 eliminated marital Masters we
have no more marital Masters we had 13
when we created the Circuit Court Tom
Cooper was the last he's now retired the
idea was that judges would be better
suited to hear marital cases and the
Masters weren't doing a good job and now
you're hearing about the judges that
aren't doing a good job so I don't think
that was the Magic Bullet but that was
attempting to lay a foundation but I'm
going to go ahead without one
um and if this is not the time in this
morning and someone else is to
um speak to this please let me know
I am sensing some growing sentiment that
domestic violence issues should be
separated out from Family Court even if
that means two people are going to now
be in two separate things because the
whole idea of of
um uh
domestic violence
is just one negative on top of all the
other issues that are civil issues
and that's the feedback I continue to
get I ponder that I just wonder
um your thoughts on that I think in most
of the courts and again we have courts
that are really small like Colebrook and
North Haverhill and we have very large
courts like Manchester and Nashua
I think most of the in most of the
courts the clerks try to schedule
domestic violence and stalking cases on
their own sort of mini docket and
Manchester for example I think every
morning there is a a list of domestic
violence cases assigned to a judge
so that they're not interspersed with
other cases going on at the same time if
that's what you're getting at Mr
chairman I think we try to do that now
oftentimes there's a criminal component
of a domestic violence case true which
is not a wooden domestic violence be by
itself a criminal case well the domestic
violence
protective order of matter is a civil is
a civil case okay
did you have your hand up Vice chair oh
on this I just want to ask you Mr
chairman if what you were acknowledging
at the point one point that judge king
just made that
domestic violence is can be both civil
and Criminal
and so that gets you in different courts
but then in addition
in the
divorce case they can be a divorce issue
and a domestic violence issue
same principles of principles meaning
ALS not Les same people involved
and one of the
realities is because people function in
their own silos
it's possible that there is a judge
involved in one part
of family
exes
uh concerns that are before the courts
and another judge is involved in another
part
of that same family's concerns and for
many reasons
it's not easy for them
to know what both the left hand and the
right hand are doing and
I don't know if there's an answer to
that is there well that's certainly true
the the fact that many divorce and
parenting cases have a domestic violence
component ideally the same judge would
handle those
but again for a variety of reasons
judges move
in the smaller courts particularly on
the front end of a domestic violence
case where there's the ex-party petition
if it's filed if it's a Colebrook or a
Lancaster or a case or North table they
might not be a judge in the in the
county so another that's going to get
shipped electronically to another judge
to rule on
um the final hearing will always be held
in the venue where it's filed hopefully
with a judge who will handle the
companion case if there is one but it
doesn't always happen
I will continue to Monitor and I will
start better recording people who are
bringing this issue to me with some
narrative this could be something at a
later date for a conversation absolutely
Mr chairman if you have a specific case
with the docket number we can take a
look at it we can look at the companion
case and we can answer more specific
questions
and I would say to my friends in the
audience who at least two of you have
very good networks of people who are
concerned with these matters
um I will be open to receiving such
information by email
thank you and yes representative long uh
thank you Mr chairman on this on the
same top topic my understanding as the
judges have access to criminal and civil
cases correct
So a family a family court judge
can
look into a criminal or civil uh with
the lit against CCN and family court if
there's a civil or Criminal
sure if I if I understand the question
correctly they can take judicial notice
of another case they typically don't do
that on their own because we can't go
outside the record of the case but if a
party said for example I want you to
take judicial notice of this case and
this docket number that's allowable okay
to follow-up follow-up yeah I wanted
that was my next question is that is
that access helpful because we're
hearing that
um of those situations and they're not
checking the criminal uh Records uh or
vice versa
I don't know if that's an issue but is
that access helpful for a family court
judge
to know what's going on in those civil
or criminal cases I I don't I'm and
maybe one of the experts behind me who
does this work every day can give you a
better answer for my answer would be it
could be but it might not be material or
relevant to the cases before the judge
at that particular time great thank you
chair recognizes the clerk
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
judge king for coming in for taking my
question I think part of what rep long
is referring to is we've heard of
instances where a temporary order
perhaps was issued in
civil court and uh Family Court
um a protective order and then another
party will go file for a temporary order
the opposite party will go file for a
temporary order and criminal court and
if they lie on the form and don't say
that there's another case you guys don't
go and look it up so then there's two
conflicting orders against each other
against the opposite parties
so it's not routine to look up so what
you're saying is unless a party asked
you to look up this other case you
wouldn't on your own go to look and see
if there was another pending case in the
other court
staff should check Odyssey to see if
there is a matter but I I'm not going to
say that it happens every single time
the the information would be available
assuming that the other case was entered
into Odyssey sometimes one party goes to
one Court another party goes to another
court it's sort of at the same time
seeking the same relief and judges May
issue competing orders not knowing and
if it hasn't been entered there's no way
we would know
um but ideally if it was in the system
and we knew that would be something we
would want we would want to take into
account
follow-up approximately how long does it
typically take to get things entered I
fully understand that you guys are are
really busy so is it usually a few days
or how long is it generally
I think I'm going to defer to judge
Ashley on that one because she's she has
more administrative experience in is in
the courts up like a cbpo a criminal
Bill protective what are those things of
that nature get entered very quickly
we don't I mean do we sometimes miss
them of course where it is human error
but they are supposed to get in in the
DV orders go in quickly they go to the
registry we have staff that stay after
hours five days a week to make sure
those are entered the FBI has really
strict requirements for getting those
orders into the database so that they're
visible to law enforcement so those
kinds of orders are processed very
quickly judge Ashley just want to add
one thing to this
um
just on the issue of the domestic
violence civil orders those are
definitely entered into same day they
have to be some people can't leave until
they're make sure that they're ordered
and they're in the system and
um and they're processed I would just
add on the issue of being able to access
other matters and you've mentioned
particularly Criminal
um they're the court does not do record
checks of folks to so if too lit against
or before us we are not doing a blanket
record check of all of their histories
that is really beyond our
Province when we're hearing a particular
case so someone as judge Kings would say
might ask us to take notice of something
because again there might be an order of
protection in a criminal charge so the
states brought a case there is an order
of protection it's a bail order of
protection that exists and it's
important for us to know that
when we're dealing with a domestic
violence case certainly to know that the
defendant is facing criminal charges but
we don't always have that information
before us and again we're hearing what
folks are bringing to us and bringing to
the table as they're trying to prove
their
burden approve in the case if that's
helpful
thank you anything further
then thank you and judge Lemire
thank you good morning
good morning chairman Pearson and the
rest of the committee
it's such a pleasure to be here I am
going to speak in just a moment about
um
really uh some of the resources we do
have some resources we might like to
have in the family division with respect
to in particular high conflict parenting
cases briefly just a little bit about me
and how I got here I am a native of New
Hampshire grew up in Northampton and
went to law school in Boston and I came
back to practice law here in New
Hampshire
in 1995 I began my practice and I
practiced in New Hampshire Maine and
Massachusetts
primarily family law but also a general
civil litigation practice I practiced
for about 14 years before I was
appointed to the bench as a marital
master and that was in 2010 January of
2010 I began that service and enjoyed it
very very much but as you heard judge
king say
um by 2011 there was already that was
when the Circuit Court was formed and as
part of that marital Masters were no
longer going to be part of that system
I was appointed uh fortunately and I am
honored to have been appointed as a
circuit court judge towards the end of
2012. so I have been a circuit court
judge now for 11 years and I've
practiced in Manchester was where I
began and that's where I served for
three years as a marital Master hearing
solely parenting and divorce and other
types of Family Division cases five days
a week and then I sat in Portsmouth for
three years and then Dover for four
years and I've been in Brentwood now for
almost four years
I I also just wanted to say that I um I
was very fortunate growing up and I was
reminded of this when judge king spoke
about our staff who are fantastic it
would be wonderful if we could maintain
the experienced staff a few that we do
have for as long as possible because
that institutional knowledge is
incredible and important to have my
mother was a staff Court assistant in
what used to be called The Domestic
Relations Department of the superior
court she started out in District Court
in Hampton and then she in Rockingham
County she was a court assistant in the
domestic relationship department and she
was there for more than 35 years before
she retired 20 years ago now and it was
through her that I
gained an affinity for the law for the
court system for the courthouse in
Brentwood in particular so it's
especially
she before she retired she did work a
little bit in the new I still call it
the new courthouse in Brentwood where I
sit now it was 1996 I believe when they
made that change from the old one on
Exeter Road
but it's almost like coming home for me
to be sitting where I am now and to be
serving the people of New Hampshire in
the way that that I and and others of us
who serve in the Family Division are are
trying very hard to do and we're trying
to do the best that we can is that the
court one of the divisions that is going
to move over to the new building
no okay so yours isn't leaking and yours
does work sort of
um
I'm not sure I understand that question
that's a Connie roof from Rockingham
County I have eyes on that complex in
Brentwood and the new one that's being
built because some of the old one
um should be demolished so I just
wondered if your part was working okay
it's working okay as far as I know as
far as I know sometimes I'm the last to
know but as far as I know
um I I also I'm very involved in the
training of the new judges that come on
I spend three full days just myself with
them on many areas of family law and as
much as I can impart upon them from my
own knowledge and experience when we do
have new uh judges come on board I'm a
member of the judicial conduct committee
um and
um so I I see another aside of
um
of what we all do in that context I
value that experience that I have very
very much and I think it also
um it it it helps me to to continue to
do the work that I do
um the way that I do it and I hope that
um I am I mean I we can all use some
improvement uh and I hope that I am
helping
um the system as much as I possibly can
because that is my own aspiration I am
married I have three adult children I
have one grandchild I just had my first
grandson born in May of this year
um and um so that's just a little bit
about me but now I want to turn to a
very important topic that I understand
is one that you're interested in looking
into and that is the use of or perhaps
what might be a future use of more
mental health professionals and other
types of Professional Resources within
the Family Division in high conflict
parenting cases these cases are just a
part of of what we do here in the Family
Division I'm not going to bore you you
probably have unless you ask I would be
happy to expand on the types of cases
that we do here within the Family
Division but
this is a part of them but this is a
very very very important but often
challenging part of what we do as Family
Division judges is to hear cases where
there is high conflict at times between
the parents that are going through
probably one of if not the most
difficult time in that family's life and
it is
um perhaps even more so for the child or
children that are involved in those
cases
as you heard and as you've discussed and
as you've mentioned
there is a lot involved Beyond just the
law there are emotions involved there
are tensions there is distrust there is
a lot involved in in the Dynamics of
these cases and we as judges do the best
that we can with the law and following
the law and the case law and the
statutory law in New Hampshire
but when we can utilize other resources
to help a family if we're able to do
that then then we want to be able to do
that our statute as you know 461a
was something that was enacted in 2005
now I still call it the new statute
because I I started practicing in this
area of law in 1995. but it it's the
um the statute that as you know governs
parental rights and responsibilities in
New Hampshire it was a sweeping overhaul
of the law back at that time it was the
parent parental rights and
responsibilities act that was enacted by
the legislature then and there was a
task force on family law that did a
two-year study at that time and it
resulted in this new statute and it
began a way of looking at these cases
differently I still remember it quite
well when it was enacted we stopped or
we tried very hard to stop using words
like custody and visitation because what
it did was it created at least the task
force thought at the time a win or lose
type of dynamic as opposed to giving
parental autonomy moving forward in
these cases and so there was a shift
towards wanting to help parents help
parties make their own decisions if they
can in a safe and healthy way that would
then be in the best interest of the
children
but there there's always a difficult
time doing that when we're also working
within what is an adversarial system the
court the courtroom with a petitioner
and a respondent we may call them
petitioner and respondent as opposed to
Plaintiff and defendant in the Family
Court setting but still it's one party
in the other party but what we have is
two parents and we have a child or
children and a family before us so as
judges the statute requires that we
support frequent and continuing contact
between each child and both parents
unless it can clearly be shown to be
detrimental to a child to do that
what we do is when they first come to
court and they file their petition
we have what we call a first appearance
session and we explain the court process
to them particularly if they don't have
attorneys or one party doesn't have an
attorney we refer them to mediation
because now under the statute mediation
is mandatory in cases involving minor
children unless a certain exception
applies and we try to help the parents
to resolve the issue on their own with
the assistance of a trained
mediator and if they can many many cases
do many cases settle even before they
reach that point when they file they've
got an agreement because they have done
that reached that cooperatively
beforehand or they they resolve the case
in mediation but there are those cases
and these are the the very challenging
ones where the parents cannot maybe they
cannot communicate will not communicate
or they communicate in a very healthy
and sometimes just horrible way with one
another that most certainly the children
are experiencing I have to imagine
outside of or within the home or homes
but we have to help the parents create a
parenting plan that is really the road
map moving forward for how they're going
to raise that child or children together
even though they're in now separate
households and it can be quite
challenging with some cases and so when
they cannot do that on their own then
it's up to us as the Family Division
judges to create a parenting plan that's
in the child or children's best
interests taking certain factors that
are in the statute into consideration
but we can only do that with the
information that we receive from the
parties themselves because we have to
make factual findings and then we have
to apply the law to those findings to
determine what's in the child's best
interests
some cases a party or a parent or the
other parent or maybe even both
have mental health issues maybe
substance use issues there may be
domestic violence in in a dynamic
involved that that
makes it difficult for a parent
especially one that's representing him
or herself to present in evidence or
information to us to help us make that
decision
in our statute 461a then there is
authorization for us to appoint we may
appoint a guardian ad litem to a case a
guardian ad litem might be appointed in
such a case because we have determined
that
um the child would benefit from someone
another party going and talking to the
parents talking to the parents
references talking to the children
themselves making a report to the court
with information that we cannot go out
and get ourselves and that for whatever
reason we may not be getting from one or
both parties it it ideally it sounds
fantastic but in reality most of the
cases that need a guardian ad litem
cannot have one because the parties
can't afford a guardian ad litem and we
cannot appoint one if the parties can't
afford to privately pay for Guardian Ad
Litem Services we used to have many
years ago a gal fund similar to the
mediation fund we have now for Indigent
parties to be able able to have that
service in their case but that has long
been gone and so there is no option now
and a guardian ad litem is quite
expensive often the hourly rate is about
120 but it could be less and often more
than that and we when we appoint a
guardian ad litem we'll put a maximum a
cap on the fees they are to charge but
as many people who have difficult cases
know that last a very long time often
unfortunately and the guardian ad litem
has a large job to do takes many hours
and in in some cases it could be several
thousands of dollars for that for that
resource to be available and then that
person reports to the court and it's
just it's it's evidence like any other
evidence we receive in the case and we
give it what weight we we believe it
deserves the parties are able to
cross-examine the guardian ad litem and
question the guardian ad items report
but it's not determinative
but it can be very helpful it's just
that we can't use it as much as we would
like to the other thing that we have is
I spoke about mediation and mediators
but in some cases if the parties can't
afford it again this is a financial
issue to a large extent we will employ
outside mental health professionals
and that may take the form of a
counselor
that will work um you know hopefully the
children if they if they need it or in
counseling the parents often will come
to court and inform me that the children
are already in counseling and I'm always
happy to hear that
um and and that's a that's something
that needs to be respected and and
protected but then what I'm talking
about is a counselor that might work
with the family as a whole or with
um the children and the parents or
something that is called a parenting
coordinator or sometimes a co-parenting
coach that would work with the parents
in particular because many of these
parents in in this small subset of cases
that are that are very high conflict
cannot communicate with one another
cannot maybe will not maybe one is
trying really really hard and the other
just won't respond or responds in an
unhealthy way
and so someone that is usually a mental
health professional counselor or perhaps
an attorney might provide services as a
parenting coordinator that would work
with the parents specifically to try and
educate them on healthy co-parenting
communication facilitate that encourage
that and try to manage that but that
again is something that's not often
covered by the party's insurance we
always check to see what they have
available for insurance coverage with
respect to counselors and the like and
there's often a health a healthy
out-of-pocket expense for that and many
people can't just simply can't afford
that
we don't have anything like that
in-house of course you've heard the
numbers that judge king shared with you
about
what we have in terms of our court staff
as it exists today
um in in a perfect nut perfect but in a
more Ideal World we would have a enough
money to be able to create a court
system that would have some in-house
professionals to assist I went to a
conference of Judges this spring with
judges from all over the United States
and outside and other countries and I
learned about some incredible work that
they're doing with overhauling their
court systems a lot of it was
spearheaded by covid-19 and in 2019 2020
when things became very difficult and
they had to really look at how they were
handling these cases making sure that
they were being treated as they should
and that these people who were their
situation isn't changing just because
there's a pandemic in fact it made it
created a whole nother set of
difficulties within the family Dynamic
and they still needed to be helped by
the court system so for instance in Los
Angeles they have re-hauled their court
system and they have court services
officers now they hired 10 right off the
bat their mental health professionals
who when a case comes in with parenting
issues they screen it and triage it
right at the beginning to determine
what's what resources does this family
need as to help them through this
process
um Australia has completely overhauled
its family court and it did take 235
million dollars from the legislature to
do it that was all of Australia mind you
but I've spoken with judges there who
helped and worked they worked very
closely with their legislature to make
this happen so that they were able to
bring in
professional Mental Health Service
people who work now as Court employees
and um and they're seeing tremendous
results and in the long term it's
helping their families and it's it's
helping the courts be more efficient but
most importantly it's helping the
children
yes would you
speculate that
a an experiment in one County with this
might be funded especially a smaller
County that thud you heard was
representative Weiler head of Finance
picking himself up off the floor but if
we did this in a smaller County with
such a triage with a few resources to
see how it works would that be something
that might be a good idea I think it
would be wonderful I I was that was a
leading question
and that's all right I'll allow those
today
um you know I I can't I can't speak for
everyone uh within the family court
system nor am I am I here attempting to
do that but I I have been doing this a
long time now and I've worked with I
don't know how many thousands of
families
um and I I'm just one I'm just one judge
but
I have found in my experience that
and even more so of late
that to have someone more qualified than
I in child psychology in in family
Dynamics
um
be involved with help with the case is
of benefit and that's not to say that
the times that that that things of that
nature have been employed have always
worked perfectly they certainly haven't
as you might imagine but I have had
cases before me where the parties agree
the parties agree they may have
attorneys the attorneys agree that
something has to happen something needs
to to change somebody needs to help this
family and it can't just be the laws of
the State of New Hampshire or anything
that I have the authority by Statute to
do and they agree that I can appoint
someone to come in as a family therapist
or somebody a parenting coordinator I
don't know that I've I've ordered that
there be one if the parties haven't been
in agreement because and I think that a
mental health professional who does this
type of work would tell you it it's not
likely to be successful if both parties
aren't on board with it
um
I
when thinking about this issue
I was reminded that that there are some
folks within the state of New Hampshire
in the mental health community and
attorneys who do primarily family law
who do offer parenting coordination
services I don't think that they're
often employed but again I think it's
the financial piece
um in in many many cases that makes that
difficult yes representative catab
E I might
yeah and thank you for taking my
question
um so right now besides parties just
agreeing to do the parenting
coordinators is there any that I
couldn't find there wasn't a statue that
necessarily allowed the court to order
them to to do so right or did I miss
something
no there is uh there is a provision
within RSA 461a that speaks to um and
it's it's in the creation of the
parenting plan itself I think it may be
in section six
um towards the end of the section Roman
numeral two or three I think
um that speaks to the fact that if we
are going to order
um parties to have or or the family to
have any counseling that we need to look
first to whether or not that's covered
by insurance
and try to select someone in the first
instance that's covered by the party's
insurance
I I don't know that there's another
Express language section within the
statute that speaks to that but there
there is at least that much that I that
I know and so from my perspective
um if there is also let me say this
though there is also some language
within the statute and also it appears I
think in the statute concerning
Guardians ad litem that allows the court
and or the guardian ad litem in uh
appropriate cases to
um to bring in outside resources to
assist with the family
um but doesn't specifically say
parenting coordinator and I think
parenting coordinator at least as far as
I know is a term that's that's it's been
a trend nationally
um in the last few years and it's not
something that has always
um at least known to me in the court
system but I think it's gaining traction
I know that in some jurisdictions uh it
the parenting coordinator may be
appointed by the court to do the things
that I've mentioned but also serves as
somewhat of an arbitrator in terms of
making being able to make a binding
decision that keeps the parents out of
court but helps them make you know if
they can't make the decision by
agreement with the that person's
assistance that parenting coordinator
can then make the decision and they're
Bound by it we wouldn't be able to do
that as New Hampshire judges there was a
case in 2020 from the New Hampshire
Supreme Court Camille k-a-m-i-l health
and in it the New Hampshire Supreme
Court indicated that um
we cannot parental rights and
responsibilities and making
determinations of parental rights and
responsibilities is something that we
are statutorily authorized to do as
judges and we can't delegate that
Authority
so we can we can bring in or ask the
parties or order the parties to work
with a counselor or a parenting
coordinator but what we can't do is say
and that parenting coordinator's
decision is final on on any particular
issue there are some jurisdictions I
think
that Minnesota is one of them they use
something called a parenting time
expediter which is I as far as I can
tell akin to a parenting coordinator
and they have the ability to make
binding decisions like that I don't
think that our at least under that case
that's just come down not just but 2020
it's recent to me
um says from the Supreme our Supreme
Court says that we can't delegate that
responsibility
follow-up so I did see in the report
that you were actually referencing
um from 19 years ago the recommendation
to have a parenting coordinator so I did
actually put in a bill regarding that
and it it was
in the sense of the parties agreeing to
go which came which was recommended from
several family law attorneys well if you
want the parties to go in and agree but
you also you're going to want to keep
the information confidential otherwise
the parties are never going to agree to
be using this if whatever they're saying
can kind of be used against them which
is I think the flip of kind of what
happens with the gal model but I guess
I'm curious about one thing with the gal
model that I've heard come up a lot and
I'm wondering if it may end up happening
with the parenting coordinator model
overall with the number of cases that
you've seen do you see
um cases being swayed one way or the
other when a party when one of the
parties is paying for the gal and the
other isn't because I'm wondering if the
same may become true and the parenting
coordinator model and I guess I know
that's going to be kind of an anecdotal
question but I'd really love your
opinion on that because you probably
know which party's paying for it and you
probably know the outcome of many of
these reports
I I think that's a very good question
and I I'm aware that many people feel
that way I think that
um we start it would ideally be that in
every case if there's to be a guardian
ad litem appointed the parties can both
afford it and we would have them share
equally in that expense then everyone
has the same stake in the process I
think and then you know I I I think that
would
um
we would hear much less of that
sentiment in that case however
what often or what sometimes will happen
one parent will want a Guardian outline
to be appointed the other parent will
not or cannot afford it or one parent
may be the parent that for which a
guardian ad litem is really necessary
because perhaps that parent is the one
who wants to move with the child
across the country to and and that would
severely impact the amount of parenting
time that the other parent would have
with that child if that were to occur
but you need to have someone that can
look into the school system there and
what the housing would be there and do
that kind of investigation that a
guardian ad litem can do that the court
cannot
and but that party
um the person who is not moving might
say well
she ought to be responsible for 100 of
that Guardian Ad Litem expense then
because that's the reason why it's
necessary in the first place and
if you look at the statute there is one
of the factors that we are to consider
when appointing a guardian ad litem
um is who is requesting it in addition
to what the finances of the parties are
it it's very difficult if both parties
cannot afford it
to appoint a guardian ad litem
if it's really if if we determine that
boy this case really needs a guardian ad
litem this child or children really need
to have a guardian ad litem in this case
to be able to present this type of
information to the court so that we can
truly or or better try to make a
determination of what's in their best
interests
um
at times if that happens and the only
way it can happen is because one parent
can afford to pay more of maybe 75
percent or even 100 percent of that
expense the other party cannot afford it
but that's the only way you can have the
guardian ad litem in the case
what sometimes will happen is the person
that is not paying for it may complain
that the guardian ad litem is is really
working for that other party I can
understand how they might feel that way
or what also sometimes happens is that
the party that's not paying for the
guardian ad litem may be having the
guardian ad litem's ear all of the time
and sending thousands of text messages
and screenshots and evidence
to help the guardian ad litem understand
what is going on in the case and then I
hear the party that is paying for it
complaining well you know he or she
ought to be paying more because they're
taking up all you know that the only
reason the guardian items fee is so high
is because the other part
it's it's a no-win situation really any
way you slice it we when we make the
initial determination of whether we're
even going to have a guardian and then
who's going to be responsible for paying
for it we have to look at all of those
factors we have to look at well do we
truly need one can the parties afford it
if one or both can't well both can't we
can't we can't appoint one if only one
can afford it or one can pay more than
the other
we try to craft the order on appointment
of guardian ad litem in such a way at
least I do
that will perhaps limit the scope of the
investigation to just what I'm
interested in in finding information
about given what I've heard to that
point in the case as being the issues
involving the child or children
we can we can limit the scope of the
appointment
but ultimately I think that the same is
true for guardian's ad litem
mediators perhaps parenting coordinators
attorneys
each of those types of professionals
involved in a case such as this
one party may be happy with that
professional and the other party maybe
not
um that is as judge king said the nature
of the type of work that we're doing the
nature of these cases
and it it may be
Justified it may not be
but it's these are the only resources
that we have at present and we can only
do what we're statutorily authorized to
do
a follow-up representative qatab thank
you Mr chairman
um so just to follow back up but are you
actually seeing that when one party is
paying versus the other that the
majority of orders are in favor of the
party that's paying or are you not
seeing that I can't say that I have ever
seen that
or that I've ever that anyone's brought
that to my attention
thank you
chair recognizes the vice chair
um
we have uh
had
discuss for this committee
um issues
relating to a judge requiring
um in layman's charts that might not be
the technical term a mental health
evaluation
that can be very expensive yes
I don't question
the need
but I wonder
how we can require
an individual
who has come to the court seeking
a satisfactory resolution
to uh
take the responsibility for
other expenses I mean it's I'm not I'm
not raising taxation without
representation issues here but um I'm
wondering
where
in uh a fair and just system
we can require someone who was who
appears before you seeking help
to
take on the responsibility of a
significant expense
it's it's a very challenging question
and it's a very that's all I ask no I I
appreciate I appreciate the question
um I here is how this is how I see it
we
we need to create a parenting plan
that's in the best interests of the
children
and
we start with the premise that the child
or children should have
continuing frequent contact with each
parent so that they have because both
parents have equal natural inherent
rights to parent that child as they come
to the courthouse those are now
competing with one another
because they're now in court
and one or the other is presenting
evidence that the other
is somehow presenting a harm to the
child
that harm could take many different
forms
I have uh you know without I can't speak
to the facts of any pending cases of
course but in general terms
certainly over the many years that I've
been doing this there have been
occasions where a parent has a very
serious alcoholism problem very serious
substance abuse problem
may have been involved in motor vehicle
accidents may have been involving the
child in the accidents
or may have what appears to be very
serious mental health illness that
perhaps is not being treated or had been
treated but currently that party is not
treating as he or she has been
recommended by their Physicians
and it's how do we then if the parents
can't themselves agree upon a parenting
plan and how they're going to share
parenting time with that child or
children
how do we as judges
um create one
that will not present any danger of harm
to that child
if a parent
presents with if we have sufficient
enough evidence to believe that there is
a serious mental health issue or a
serious substance use issue or maybe one
the evidence is clear enough because the
the statute says it has to be clearly
demonstrated that it's detrimental to a
child
um to order something other than
continuing frequent contact with both
parents
how how do we
how do how do we not put guidelines in
place or do something to learn what
exactly the issue is so that if it can
be
safe for that child
to be with that parent we can work that
into the parenting plan
so it it's it's similar to
um you know we judges will order where
it's appropriate supervised parenting
time
and as you know there there are now few
and far between but there are
supervision centers that provide these
services
um in cases where there is evidence of
of some some presentation of harm to a
child
sufficient enough for that judge to
believe that the parenting time should
be supervised then it's ordered to be
supervised if we can put safeguards in
place that will protect the child
so that we can make orders that are in
that child's best interests so that if
possible that child can have as much
healthy safe time with each parent
um
then
that's that's what we have as an
opportunity to do only however if the
parties can afford it and I'm very very
understanding of that issue
if a parent is in front of us because
they're representing themselves often
it's because they cannot afford an
attorney to represent them and then if
you're going to add on that a guardian
ad litem expense counseling expense
supervised visitation expense perhaps
I'm we all understand that that that is
something that may be insurmountable
they may not be able to do but we they
file a financial affidavit with us for
almost every hearing where there is
going to be some type of I I for
instance if someone asks me to appoint a
guardian ad litem I cannot and won't do
it until they have both filed Financial
affidavits sworn to under oath that
explain to me what their financial
situation is so that I can determine if
they can afford it and how to allocate
it the same is with respect to the
counseling I mean I you know there may
be many many cases where I I would like
to have someone have a mental health
evaluation but I I don't order it
because I they cannot afford it
representative Smith for a follow-up
I apologize I thought you had finished
one before I began to speak so go ahead
forgive me
um
I'm very troubled
by this
um and
I want I want to ask two parts of this
if the chair would permit me to do that
is there any
let's forget about Australia or New
Zealand or Finland or Sweden I think
everybody's supposed to be happy
um
is there any state
where these issues are not before
a court
but are in another venue
not to my knowledge
and I believe I haven't studied every
state but I would
I would believe that every family court
in the United States is experiencing
these same issues these same
difficulties which have only been
exacerbated in recent years I think you
know the covid pandemic has has really
created even more of a mental health
crisis I think
the chair asks the committee researcher
to get us some information as to whether
any other United States state
in family court has the same difficulty
of lack of funding or is there a state
that has considerable funding available
for GIS and some other things like that
thank you my answer comes from my own
experience
um I I've been fortunate that the
conference that I attended this spring
there was a grant fortunately that
allowed me to go it was the association
of family and conciliation courts and it
was all it was a judge's conference and
there were judges there from all of the
United States and Beyond as I mentioned
and I spoke with many many other judges
and I and I saw presentations by many
judges from all over the United States
and what we were all finding is that we
are all experiencing or many of us I
should say are experiencing a lot of the
same a lot of the same challenges within
our family court systems do you wish to
follow up I in my mind for these months
is a comment that was made before this
committee
to buy a one of your former colleagues
um
Annette Gordon
who said that we have to understand that
the responsibility of the Court
is not to solve the underlying problem
and
um I have over the years
whatever hat he was wearing at the time
she found Ned's comments to be astute
um
I recognize the correctness of what he
said
which causes me to say then what are we
doing
and I don't see the answer are we in
fact helping
families
who are
experiencing
difficulties
get to a point where although we're not
solving the problem
we are making it possible
for the state interest the state's
interest is not in the marriage that's a
business Arrangement it always has been
for
you know since time began but in
protecting
children and is there
a better way
for us to protect
the children
you don't have to answer but that is
what I'm struggling with I I'd like to
answer and I'd like to have more
conversation with you about this because
it's something I am extremely interested
in
finding out for myself I understand
intellectually I understand why
we have these cases before us I
understand that the state has a parent's
Patriot power when minor children are
involved and that is why when parents
who have these equal natural inherent
rights to parent their children under
the Constitution when they are at
conflict when they are at odds with each
other
um why then we are
employed to
settle that dispute so to speak and then
the question is how do we do that and
what is the best way to do that
of course we have to do we have to be
guided by the statutes by by our the
legislation that that we have that
enables us to do what we do the case law
that comes down from our Supreme Court
certainly which interprets that and and
helps us in what we do
But ultimately it's apparent in case a
divorce case with children or a
parenting case is extraordinarily
different than any other type of case
that we see within the circuit court or
that the Superior Court sees and
and it's it's different for a myriad of
reasons I don't need to explain to you
you all understand why
um and so it doesn't fit as neatly
um perhaps
um and it isn't as easy I would argue to
be a judge on these types of cases as in
say you know every once in a while when
I was on the regular docket of the
Circuit Court I I would have to sit in
District Division and do criminal
arraignments and and things of that
nature and sometimes I did the Civil
docket and I heard small claims actions
and and payment hearings and I I looked
forward to those days they were a nice
break because these are difficult
difficult cases judge lemir I'm going to
have to break in now with others going
to be called forward
um on October 17th which is a Tuesday at
10 30 a.m the subcommittee slash work
group of the special committee will be
addressing the issue of gal and
parenting plans and all of that it's the
only subgroup I don't have in my notes
as to who's on it
anybody here or the clerk has is my
external memory stick so I'm chairing it
and
um it'll be rep long rep Greg and rep
wanza are also on it and who else Greg
and long and lonza Lanza okay so the
four of you
um will be addressing this issue and uh
I don't Mr chair for indulging my
philosophical and I would just suggest
that your other training might come in
here where perhaps the answer is to say
well I'm going to divide the child
I have two day jobs one of them is an
Episcopal priest of a small Church the
second one is part-time Chief Executive
Officer of a Wellness Center that has
counselors and Family Practice
Physicians so yes and I'm sorry if I
spoke long on the issue but no that's
fine I very much appreciate Vice uh
chair Smith's um
you're you're your interest I was going
to say would it be appropriate for the
members of the special committee work
group to
um
use you as a further resource I I would
be happy to have any opportunity to help
if there is a way that we can improve
upon what we already have in a way that
that helps us as judges but more
importantly helps the families and
children that appear before us so it
won't go on to the broadcast recording
if you would either if you're here when
we adjourn you can do it in person if
you have to leave could you leave
whatever contact information you are
allowed to give them with the researcher
and they will check with her I'd be
happy to okay thank you so much thank
you all
brief
not a legal brief just a short just a
brief brief okay uh thank you Mr
chairman I yeah I just uh yeah I would
like that contact information I have a
lot of questions on the gal in parenting
um that I'll reserve for uh when I have
a conversation with you
um but as we were talking is this
is this 95 or more
just the high conflict or is some of
this tied into the 80 percent of the
nine months that
um
get resolved is it I no doubt there is
some of it tied into the other eighty
percent
um I you know
but where we see the most need
um are the cases that do last the
longest that um that they they just they
I don't have the expertise the mental
health expertise and what have you to
really therapeutically help these
families the way that they they may need
in addition to helping them as much as I
can in the legal context okay thank you
thank you thank you all very much
and judge king who would you like to
present before
would be next to talk about the Rules of
Evidence I just wanted
um Vice chair Smith to know that I'll
get this in the right order Senator
judge representative now referee Ned
Gordon did four nces for us last week
and I believe all four settled so he's
doing a great job in his new role as a
neutral case evaluator for the circuit
board doesn't surprise and the chair
recognizes judge mace
and before you begin sir the
um
this committee is considering the
question of Rules of Evidence
there are two bills before another
committee I chair children and family
law
in a stroke of
um Insanity I appointed the same people
to both groups because
the clerk of the house said we could not
have a joint meeting so we cannot have a
joint meeting of the five of us what we
can have is a meeting on a two retained
bills on Rules of Evidence in family
court with Pearson and the chair ball
McMahon Greg and long who amazingly then
will remember what we did when we think
about it here
so that session will be I think it is on
October 10th next Tuesday in this room
children and family law Rules of
Evidence Pearson McMahon who sends his
regrets he had a family health issue so
you can Mark him excused long Greg and
ball so with that the chair recognizes
judge mace this by the way is what a
paper printout of the Rules of Evidence
look like I didn't bring my own copy and
thanks to the Supreme Court for giving
me a huge stack the commonality of which
is LexisNexis which apparently I'm
signed up for now
um and that has been read four times
with the footnotes and even some
cross-referencing to all those books who
live over there so bring it on Rules of
Evidence
thank you Mr chairman and I sincerely
appreciate the opportunity to address
this body I I am a circuit court judge
as you know I sit in the Franklin
Circuit Court uh it's hard to believe
now but I'm entering my sixth year as a
judge in October of this year uh before
that I was a civil litigator for
approximately 20 years uh 10 of which
were devoted almost exclusively to
family law in New Hampshire and in
Vermont I practiced in the Upper Valley
and apropov our discussion today about
evidence I thought it uh wise to point
out at the outset that when I practiced
family law I practice family law in New
Hampshire and in Vermont and in Vermont
the formal Rules of Evidence apply to
those proceedings so I have quite a lot
of experience in both settings and I can
I can tell you uh with uh near 100
certainty that the general tenor of the
litigation that judge Lemire so
eloquently described does not change
whether or not the rules apply or not
um so as a preferatory comment we're
still dealing with families in crisis
families who are going through trauma
and whether or not that is filtered to
us through the through the Rules of
Evidence or not
um is is not uh terribly apparent to me
at least uh so what I thought I would do
uh for the committee if it uh if it
pleases you is I I wanted you to First
be aware if you're not of exactly what
kinds of cases we hear in the Family
Division what Rules of Evidence apply to
those subcategories and what burdens of
proof we have to deal with because those
are all relevant when we talk about the
Rules of Evidence it matters greatly
what type of case we're talking about
and it matters greatly what the actual
burden of proof is in a particular case
type so the Family Division here is of
course divorce and parenting cases judge
Lemire was addressing those we hear
domestic violence cases I think there
were some questions of judge king and
judge Ashley about how those are filed
we hear guardianship cases for juvenile
animals we hear abuse and neglect cases
brought by the division of children
youth and families for children who are
suspected of being abused or neglected
we hear termination of parental rights
cases we hear delinquency cases and we
hear Chin's cases of course chins is an
acronym for child in need of services so
in each case type we have a series of
rules and statutes that tell us what
sort of evidentiary territory we're in
starting with divorce and parenting we
have a family division rule 2.2 that
tells us the rules of evidence do not
apply it does not mean they don't exist
it just means that we can apply them
when they would enhance quote the
predictable orderly fair and reliable
presentation of evidence so rule 2.1 of
the Family Division rule tells us that
those apply to divorce and parenting
cases turning to domestic violence cases
those of course are parties seeking
protective orders uh against the
existence of a protected relationship
marriage child in common uh
people related by blood or affinity and
the like the rules exist and what that
statute is RSA 173 B3 Roman 8. the rules
exist but they're relaxed which means
that we're not bound by the technical
Rules of Evidence the burden of proof in
those cases is preponderance so you have
to understand that when we're reviewing
these cases the rules do apply they are
relaxed but it's preponderance in other
words it's a more likely than not
standard but there would be a ruling as
to each particular bit of evidence
offered
uh typically yes uh if if they're
conducted like most hearings you would
expect to be conducted we have three
General categories of evidence we're
looking for in a domestic violence case
we're looking for first and foremost the
existence of a protected relationship
under 173b we're looking for a
prohibited act which is enumerated in
173 but it really mirrors uh some of the
sections of our criminal code and then
of course the third prong which is the
most difficult is whether or not they
responded in a case like that represents
a present credible threat to the
petitioner's safety so it's it's in
those three categories that that
evidence would fall it's almost never
contested that there's a there's a
protected relationship it's generally
pretty obvious this is a married couple
this is a couple with a child in common
this is uh an adult with a you know
another adult child for example that
would be a consequinity relationship uh
so that we don't really get into too
much trouble there in terms of evidence
it can get a little more complicated
when we're talking about the prohibited
action yeah and I would I would add
importantly it's really critical to note
and and I think representative Smith you
touched upon this or for forgive me it
might have been uh representative qatab
when you uh referenced someone seeking
relief in another case type it is often
the case that someone who is a
respondent in a domestic violence action
is also going to be a defendant and a
parallel criminal case so it's best
practices and we generally follow this
before we allow respondents to testify
in these cases we give them a general
Fifth Amendment warning they are public
recorded proceedings and anything they
say on that record could be used against
them in a separate criminal proceeding
so it's important for getting the rules
of evidence for a minute that you've
given that General constitutional
warning because we are going to be
talking about evidence on the record it
is a lower evidentiary threshold but it
is still alive proceeding and we need to
make sure that defendants that appear in
those cases are mindful that they may be
putting themselves into criminal
Jeopardy by testifying uh the next
category of cases is guardianships these
are juveniles or minors that are without
appropriate parental care or supervision
it's generally the same evidentiary
standard that we apply in domestic
violence cases we apply RSA 463 eight
Roman one again the rules apply but
we're not bound by their technical
application there are two types of
burdens of proof and guardianship cases
of this stripe if it's a guardianship
brought by grandparents because of a of
substance abuse or it's agreed that in
other words by consent guardianship is
necessary the burden of proof is
preponderance of the evidence if it's
contested it's clear and convincing
evidence so it's that evidential burden
that exists between preponderance and
proof Beyond A Reasonable Doubt so that
we we again in these cases we're not
bound by the technical rules they apply
but if it's contested we're looking at a
much higher evidentiary burden that
typically means as a fact finder looking
at the Rules of Evidence we're going to
be a little more on top of what we might
let in under a relaxed standard because
the burden of proof is higher in other
words it needs to be generally more
reliable according to the legislature uh
turning to abuse and neglect cases these
are brought by dcyf against parents and
Guardians for the suspected abuse and
neglect of a child we are looking at
evidence from a statute it's 169 C 12.
that again is telling us that the rules
are relaxed there's one exception in
that statute that's important to note if
the division brings forward prior and
I'm sorry I'm looking right through this
speaker at you I'm trying not to ignore
you uh that if the division brings prior
assessments or prior reports to
demonstrate a pattern of conduct the
statute actually makes the admission of
those reports mandatory there's a shell
in that statute and that's an important
evidential consideration because those
documents and I can tell you with lots
and lots of experience judge Ashley far
more they are wrecked with hearsay
evidence it is almost all hearsay but
those come in if offered to demonstrate
a pattern irrespective of whether the
rules apply or not so that's something
we have to Grapple with as well the next
section is tpr's termination of parental
rights those are broad pursuant to 170c
again we're talking about uh
uh the same sort of evidentiary approach
but there are two what I find to be uh
distinctive features from an evidentiary
perspective about those case types uh in
particular the right we're talking about
the termination of parental rights is is
the most severe sanction I think we can
issue uh as Circuit Court judges it's
the one we all fear the most it is the
most serious we're talking talking about
severing a fundamental parental liberty
interest that has existed and has been
recognized by courts across the country
for centuries it's embodied in Troxel
versus Granville which is a U.S Supreme
Court on point so when we're dealing
with the burden of proof it is proof
Beyond a reasonable doubt we apply the
same burden of proof that we do to a
murder case because we are talking about
divesting someone of a fundamental
parental liberty interest for time and
memorium so it's it's important to
recognize that we're in that subcategory
of cases we are dealing with proof
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt the statute
that apply applies to how we view
evidence also has some mandatory
language about confrontation so if
someone is going to be testifying to a
report that they've made they need to be
on the witness stand and testifying live
so we do have some discretion about what
we are going to let in but the
legislature has told us quite clearly we
are at the the highest evidentiary
burden in those cases and the the
testifying Witnesses need to be
testifying they're alive to what they've
observed not necessarily repeating what
stated in a report
I
turning lastly to two uh somewhat
related case types we have 169 B which
is our delinquency code and we have 169
D Delta which is our chins statute so
the delinquency code you can think more
or less of our code of criminal
procedure for juveniles the formal Rules
of Evidence do apply it is proof Beyond
A Reasonable Doubt and it's generally
the same for chins although in Chin's
cases we typically see a lot of evidence
coming in without objection because in
those cases we're typically solely
focused on the welfare of a child and
it's usually brought I wouldn't say all
the time by agreement but it does come
in Often by agreement or by stipulation
or what we call a plea of true if it's
not we do have the same evidentiary
burden of proof it is proof Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt so that is generally
speaking on what we encounter in terms
of the rules of evidence and the burdens
of proof across each case type I wanted
to make that clear before I started
taking questions because what I've just
listed with divorce and parenting
domestic violence guardianships abuse
and neglect termination of parental
rights cases delinquency and Chin's
cases those are a day in the life and
the Family Division and so you can see
that we have to shift gears all day long
between different evidentiary standards
and different burdens proof and so it
can get a little murky if we're not
clear about what case type we're talking
about page 15 of Rules of Evidence say
that evidence may be excluded if it's
probative value is substantially
outweighed by the danger of prejudice or
confusion is that whole does that hold
all through your list or are there items
on there where
weight is given a little bit more one
way or the other I would say as a
general proposition that sets all the
way through I I think that the
difference
I think it's important to make a
distinction between the application of
that rule
in front of a jury and a judge sitting
as Judge Andrew the danger of unfair
Prejudice I think my opinion is lessened
because we're trained we're trained
lures and we're judges we understand
that someone may be throwing an exhibit
in to try to inflame the Trier fact as
judge Lemire discussed in these cases we
see lots of inflammatory evidence and
we're very unlikely to be swayed by
something that would be outweighing its
probative value the comment of the jury
will disregard what you just heard
sure they will right I typically say
Mike disregard that
questions representative long
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
judge
um so you refer to a lot of the rules uh
has relaxed uh is is there a definition
of relaxed yes it the the definition is
actually from this body it is that the
technical Rules of Evidence don't apply
so when we talk about the technical
application of the Rules of Evidence you
can think of I heard someone was a fan
of Law and Order uh you can you can
think of how these these rules would be
applied in a criminal case in other
words someone would make a hearsay
objection or object to a form of
character evidence of or bad ax evidence
uh someone would be there trying to uh
you think of a tax fraud case they'd I'd
be presenting a summary of voluminous
exhibits and the documents wouldn't be
in the courtroom so if let's take that
last example if I was technically
applying the rules of evidence and I'm
an expert accountant and I'm handing you
a spreadsheet if the backup
documentation is in the courtroom it's
not coming in
so that's the technical application I'm
I am standing on this book saying that's
what the rule says relaxing it uh would
be let's say it would happen and like
the complex uh uh asset cases that judge
Lemire referred to are a great example
if we have a closely held family
Corporation for example we have
voluminous exhibits we've got lots of
tax returns bank statements QuickBook
printouts and the like sometimes the
lawyers will agree that the summaries
can come in without the exhibits being
in the room so I can relax that
technical application and by stipulation
that's one example of what it means to
relax the technical application of the
rule that's right thank you I would like
to read
um into the
um
recording the reporters notes to rule
102.
and also it says New Hampshire is
identical to the corresponding Federal
rule this is reporters notes rule 102. I
I don't have a Pages six and seven the
philosophical underpinnings of these
rules
which are a to prefer the pursuit of
General normative goals to the strict
construction of inflexible technical
rules
B to permit the Court's sufficient
latitude to fairly decide issues where
strictly constructed rules would tend to
compete or conflict and see to favor the
pursuit of the truth in a fair and just
determination of issues over fastidious
adheritance to the letter of codified or
common law that pretty well
says it to me I mean there's more
statements further on in in Rules of
Evidence but that seems to me the big
ballpark of why in Family Court The
Rules of Evidence do not have to
strictly apply and I think if we're
looking at this from a purely practical
perspective if we're forgetting all of
the statutes that I reference about the
varying uh evidentiary standards and
burdens of proof If we think about best
interests of the child that that is a
pervasive theme through all of the case
types that I I've just referenced in
during my testimony it is particularly
cute
uh any best best interest determination
we need to make an abuse neglect case in
cases and termination of parental rights
cases and it's important to recognize
that our Supreme Court has uh
differentiated between the proof Beyond
a reasonable doubt that the dcyf must uh
prove Beyond a reason without the
contents of the petition or if it's a
private lit again the same standard but
that that the concept of best interest
of the child is not it in and of itself
an evidentiary fact it's an examination
of possible outcomes that are most
optimal for the child and were
instructed to give those priority so in
a sense we can't really get at that
determination if we're applying these
rules because we're not actually trying
to establish matters of fact we're
trying to weigh outcomes for children so
it makes sense if you look at it from
that framing that we wouldn't be bound
necessarily by the technical rules if
we're trying to get at the heart of a
best interest determination
the two retained builds that was
submitted several months ago but I would
ask my committee to retain them because
I knew this was about to happen
um
spoke to issues of
uh why does the judge keep admitting
a motion to accept this this evidence
this evidence that evidence that
evidence all it's doing is unnecessarily
delaying and I'm looking at um
um rule 403 the court May exclude
relevant evidence if the probative value
is substantially outweighed by undue
delay wasting time
needlessly presenting cumulative
evidence evidence that does not add to
what is being considered so there is a
question that those those are relative
terms undo is is not an objective thing
so how then would uh Family Division of
Circuit Court take a look at issues
where some would say too much evidence
is being admitted in violation of rule
that's that's an excellent question
um beginning with some advice I got from
a a mentor who is a excellent trial or
is unfortunately not with us anymore
she told me it was my former law partner
that if you're getting everything in
you're in big trouble
in other words if everything you're
trying to offer as evidence is coming
into evidence it's not really mattering
necessarily to the judge
that little quip aside I will say that
that is one of the more difficult tasks
we have uh and and I'll my sense of why
it's difficult is that when we're in
divorce and parenting cases in
particular we're talking about the two
things that are more important to us
people than anything else that is our
children and the fruits of our Labor uh
so you are going to try your level best
to try to tell the judge everything you
can think of to hang on to those two
things that is a very understandable
human instinct we try to be
compassionate about that but we have
very very compact long dockets you heard
judge king tell you about how little
time we have to hear these cases so that
is one of those gray areas where we just
have to make a gut call discretionary
decision on the record often that we
need to cut off a line of questioning
because we've heard someone say this
parent is a good parent they bring it in
other witness this parent is a good
parent they bring in another witness
this parent is a good parent if we did
all trials like that divorcing couples
would line up 57 neighbors long and we'd
have month-long trials about a parenting
case we obviously can't do that so it is
one of those areas I just don't have a
good answer for you representative
Pearson I what I what I can tell you is
that
ideally the judge that's hearing the
case has trial experience and
understands uh the limits of relevance
and when it's kind of getting a little
long in the tooth and I've it's been my
practice and I'm sure it's been judges
Kings Ashley and lemire's practice that
if you've gotten the point you can tell
Council or the pro se litigant I've
heard you I'm inclined to find that you
have a number of people that are willing
to say x y or Z so there's no bright
line there but it is something we need
to be mindful from and that is really a
Time conservation question and I think
that's right in 403 representative
Pearson I think that's that's
accumulation
representative catab
thank you chairman Pearson and thank you
for taking my question
um I have a kind of two questions in in
one so regarding
um civil domestic violence cases that
are not criminal yet are constitutional
warnings required at all and then also
How does Discovery work and domestic
violence cases those are both excellent
questions uh so the warning I don't
believe is required I'm unaware of a
mandate that we have as judges to issue
that warning I find it just best
practices and I know a lot of my
colleagues share the same that in the
Family Division in particular it is very
common for us to see three cases
co-occur a divorce and parenting case a
civil domestic violence case and a
district court criminal case involving
the same parties because we sometimes
know that's out there and I think you
heard that it's not exactly an exact
science that we are going to be aware of
all three case types at any given time
but because there is the possibility of
self-incrimination there is a fifth
amendment implication
we are the stewards of the Constitution
and the courtroom and personally
speaking I think it's important to try
to uphold those rights whenever we are
aware of them and can articulate them
and so if someone particularly an
unrepresented party is sitting there and
facing criminal charges as well it I
don't think hurts to say
you know you might consider you have a
fifth minute right Fifth Amendment right
against self-incrimination it does leave
them in a terrible spot because having
said that they're going to have to elect
typically by themselves without a lawyer
whether they want to defend against it
and so I typically say look you are
going to be in this position I'm going
to take this petition is uncontroverted
if you don't testify but it is your
right not to and it's at least important
to acknowledge that right so I don't
believe it's a mandate but I believe
it's best practices to do they answer
your question
follow up
yeah but I guess the part that I'm
struggling with here
we are taking away somebody's Liberties
right in that process of doing so and
then we're kind of binding them well
okay you can choose to testify against
yourself if you want or not but we're
also I mean there is a constitutional
requirement if we're going to take away
somebody's Liberties that we are going
to give them an attorney if they can't
afford one also so do we do we offer
that ever in the civil cases or we don't
we do not we are not authorized to offer
that in civil cases for the same reason
we're not authorized to give divorcing
parents lawyers it's a civil proceeding
and as I mentioned uh you know I I maybe
I didn't make it clear enough but I do
try to acknowledge that very difficult
position that that litigan's going to
find hemores helps him or herself in
which is that you you know you may be
deprived of a liberty interest I to
preserve a Fifth Amendment right in a
criminal case and it's a it's an awful
position to be in as a litigant I
certainly recognize that but we don't
have the statutory authorization to get
around that it just exists follow-up
if a party so I know that there is a
clause uh allowing under the rules that
if somebody is of good character that
they could be allowed to
I don't want to say represent somebody
but be allowed to to go to court with
somebody and that's at the judge's
discretion so typically if somebody
doesn't want to have to testify against
themselves because there's a there's a
fifth amendment issue would you
typically
uh Grant somebody's petition to allow
somebody of good character to speak on
their behalf uh so let me make sure I
understand the question because it's an
interesting one so if I'm a respondent
in a domestic violence case in other
words someone's brought one against me
and I bring
a third party to speak for me
what is the third party telling me
I guess that's my question
so I think they'd be able to at least
ask questions of the other person and
point out things that are into evidence
without actually testifying because they
can say according to this report XYZ but
they're not testifying that that's
actually true versus
when the person's doing it themselves
they're kind of implying that they're
testing for that right and that's an
important Nuance point and I neglected
to mention that you can cross-examine
the petitioner as the defendant and not
waive your fifth amendment rights when I
see Pro seis do that I still give them
that warning because they may
inadvertently incriminate themselves in
the way they ask a question so sometimes
when you ask a question on
cross-examination you need to embed the
question with particular facts that you
want discussed
that's tricky if you really don't know
how uh how cross-examination works so
the the answer is yes you you can
preserve your fifth amendment rights and
still ask the petitioner questions it is
of course far better to let a lawyer do
that uh but it's not always the case
that we have that luxury in fact it's
between 85 and 90 not the case
one of the issues that has been raised
to Children and Family Law is the judge
made an error in admitting that piece of
evidence and again rule 103 you've got
to say you're honor I object and if I'm
not mistaken why what is the nature of
the objection and I don't like it isn't
valid
but it has to be done that or or in a
timely manner I think yes and if the
error is in admitting the evidence the
party objects in a timely matter with a
motion to strike and gives the grounds
if the era is an excluding of evidence
the party informs the court of the
substance of the evidence and why it
should be admitted but that has to be
done in real time it does have to be
done therefore if it is not You've Lost
That Right should it be appealed
um
the evidence is is still part of what's
being passed on that's a more nuanced
question I I think that we're talking
about two things we may be talking about
preserving the objection and preserving
the issue for appeal and then on the
other hand plain error uh that that even
though someone may not have preserved a
particular objection they might have
just said objection and maybe the judge
just waved It Off
if it was still plain error that it came
in it can still be addressed by the
Appellate Court but it is best practices
again to have that discussion with the
litigant objecting on the record about
what the objection is it's incredibly
difficult I'll say it that way I'll use
that strong language with Pro Se
litigants who don't know the rules of
evidence they may be saying I am jacked
it's my experience it's often the case
that the objection is a disagreement
it's not actually an objection but if it
is an objection you need to try to
assess out what they're objecting to in
terms of its form and then trying to
make a ruling on the record and if the
judge makes an error that reasonable
parties would conclude was an error on
the part of a judge if it's a harmless
error that doesn't affect the decision
the decision would have gone the same
way irrespective then that does not
poison things that is the harmless error
standard correct okay correct but it is
the case that the Supreme Court can
always look at an evidentiary ruling be
made in overrules of Iran now here's my
big ask okay
because I've got to preside over
to retain build hearings
that are coming at The Rules of Evidence
it seems to me from some of what we've
been saying today and some other things
we've been saying at other times
better instruction of pro se litigants
might be in order because
um I wouldn't have known these things
um
but people who are going to court and
object and the objection is incorrect
it's not timely or it's not given reason
for may not understand that wouldn't
they be hoped if in their own Pro Se
preparation there was more information
than provided I've not looked at the the
videos I've not read the documents yet
but it seems to me from the hearings
that we've been conducting nobody knew
these things and several other things
how would you think that might play out
that I I think more information is
always better this is designed to help
us get at truth that's fundamentally
what this is and so if we can if we can
better educate people that are appearing
before us about how these apply in what
cases they apply to what degree they
apply what burdens of proof they have
um that is I think going to be in All
Ships rise situation
um I don't see that there's any harm in
that at all uh
The Rules of Evidence are difficult even
for lawyers but but more information is
always better
let me go further did you did you have a
question
okay
the separation of powers because the
legislature is making some
we guess laws affecting the Judiciary so
page 78
um opinion of the justices
page 78. the legislature has no more
right to break down The rules prescribed
by the court to assure fundamental due
process in criminal and civil court
trials than the court has to prescribe
the moon and manner in which the
legislature shall perform its
legislative duties wow
I'm trying to see where the line is
um reporters notes on rule 501 which is
as as you know the section on privileged
testimony I qualify under 502 medical
and 505 clergy so I'm really on that
section but the reporters note on 501
which is the introductory section to
that page 97 says although the principal
statutory privilege recognizes the
inherent right of the legislature to
deal with such matters Provisions have
been made established in the rules
um in the rules the saving for statutory
privileges is that just for the 500
section or is that for everything
because I'm trying to put what I see is
possibly contradictory statements about
the role of the legislature so Mr
chairman I believe you're you're talking
about what our Supreme Court wrestle
with and the plot and Davis decision I
looked that one up actually those are
those are very very difficult lines to
discern and a separation of powers
setting uh so the the best way I can
think to answer that question is is to
to reference my prior testimony about
what you all have told us are the degree
to which the Rules of Evidence apply in
a particular case type and what burden
of proof applies to that case type as a
matter of statute
so that is clearly in the legislature's
lane
how we conduct a hearing in other words
how we interpret evidence let in
evidence we're really talking about the
lenses through which we view facts and
establish facts
that is clearly a Judicial function so I
I think the line is somewhere between
and I confess it's gray and I'm not
convinced it's clear and either decision
I referenced uh but I would I would
submit that when the legislature
promulgates the law the legislature is
perfectly within its right to tell us
whether or not particular rules should
apply and if not if so but in any case
what the standard of proof is
but once we get into the courtroom
how evidence is presented to the
tribunal is purely a Judicial function
and so the interpretation of the Rules
of Evidence would always be within the
Judiciary this is the best answer I can
give the Supreme Court of which being
the final Arbiter page Supreme Court
being the final corporate so it sounds
like a good collaborative effort here
where we're talking with each other and
not at each other absolutely would be
the best way to go forward which is why
I have several things in here thinking
that a nice sit down would be preferable
to our filing an LSR uncertainty
absolutely and as judge Lemire made
clear uh we are always interested we're
uh in for opportunities where we can
share those sorts of insights we want to
get it right when you tell us that the
technical rules are relaxed and we have
to go figure out what that means if we
have a dialogue about what that means
even better uh Clarity is better than
not having Clarity and could I ask
anyone who knows this to what degree
would that dialogue be permissible and
not violating 91a I would defer to judge
king and judge Ashley
on that question all right well then
even better I've got a lawyer right
thank you so much and would you drop off
or give us the five of us who are going
to be looking at Rules of Evidence next
Tuesday morning or if you have to leave
to the research assistant your contact
information uh because I'll give you 24
hours and then I'll call you I'm thank
you so more than happy to do so thank
you for the opportunity and one question
representative I'm sorry Mr chairman
forgive me
oh yes I I did promise to uh carry a
point forward and I believe I began with
a discussion about being a family law
practitioner uh in a state where the
Rules of Evidence apply uh if we're
talking about procedural fairness and
Vermont The Rules of Evidence apply to
family proceedings if you want to watch
a pro se litigant go from terrified in
New Hampshire to terrified and totally
lost apply the rules of evidence in a
formal way it makes it next to
Impossible uh for a pro se litigant to
get a point across when the formal rules
apply so I would just leave you with
that comment that these strict technical
application of this book would make it
10 times harder for a pro se litigant to
try a case and we're dealing with 90 of
the people so it's your testimony that
Vermont and New Hampshire are not just
upside down in terms of what they look
like on a map and divided by a river
thank you sir thank you representative
ball
thank you chairman Pearson I'm sorry I
just said one yes please yes I apologize
that's okay thank you for being here
um one of the questions that kept coming
up before us and and we were actually a
little bit surprised those of us who
visited one of the courthouses
um is the idea of presumption of 50 50
parenting
um and we were surprised to hear that
that's not always the case with the
judges we everyone seemed to assume that
that was a presumption that that's what
the best interest of the child was but
was surprised to hear that that is not
the case
um so what I'm wondering is if it's not
the case how is anything less than that
um warranted and if you're the if you're
the parent not getting if you're getting
less than 50 percent of the time how do
you present evidence to say that that
ruling may not be in the best interest
of the child
um that was one part of my question I'm
just wondering what your Viewpoint is on
that so the answer is actually in in
your question itself so I we deal with
two subsections of 461a when we're
looking at that 461 A2 which is the
legislature statement of purpose we
presume children do best when both
parents have a meaningful involvement in
their children's lives meaningful of
course is not defined so we look to 461
A6 which are the best interest factors
and there are many and it is in those
factors that we weigh evidence about
the time children spend with each parent
as a best interest consideration we're
talking about a vast territory of
evidence and I can't give you any
specifics because I would have to see a
factual presentation to tell you how I
would weigh such a determination
filtered through 461a in terms of the
best interest factors but that the
there's no presumption that
that exists currently it tells us to
take the 461a2 framing to go into 461a
and weigh those factors against the
framing it may not look exactly 50 50
sometimes there's a variance sometimes
there's a very compelling safety reason
where it may not be unfortunately in the
state and we're I'm not talking out of
turn here we have a very serious opiate
addiction problem and some parents May
simply not be suitable at a particular
time for Shared Parenting so that's a
best interest Factor we'd have to weigh
so it is very very much a fact specific
and case-by-case determination
I was I guess I'm taking that clean case
where the barring all of those extra
things that there seems to be
um sometimes
the people that came before us to
testify were not able to understand it
there was also one person who testified
and I'm just curious
um and he said that he was found not
guilty in a criminal court but yet came
to the civil court and lost full custody
of his child is that
um something that happens or I mean
that's where we a lot of what was coming
before us just to clarify is people were
concerned that there was a weaponization
of the civil court and that's what we're
con I'm particularly concerned about
the weaponization of court is something
that we should all be concerned about
abusing legal process is something we
should all be concerned about there's no
doubt about that I can only answer your
question I think you're asking me a
specific question that someone it sounds
like had a criminal charge and there was
an acquittal that
They Carried into family court and said
hey I was acquitted of what they accused
me from accuse me about but you have to
remember again this is why I was careful
to lay out the burden's proof that's
proof Beyond A Reasonable Doubt when the
Family Vision we're typically at a
preponderance standard so we are that is
another gray area that we have to
wrestle with uh wrestle with often now
if a case has gone to a jury and a jury
has decided that some some thing did not
happen that's something we would
consider that would be uh some we were
talking about judicial notice at some
point a litigator if representing that
party would point out a jury of this
person's peers who's acquitted this
person of this particular fact
we could notice that docket as evidence
that 12 people took a look at it and
said no it didn't happen so we would
certainly pay close attention to that
but I would have to know a lot more
about that I was just curious because
that did come up often about the
weaponization part
um thank you very much I appreciate your
time pleasure to be here thank you thank
you before we move on to the next person
I have a printed out on my own printer
the complete rules of evidence that
looks like that when somebody gives you
one and uh in terms of Representative
long Greg or ball does anybody want this
for next week
does anybody my age want this for next
week
you may have it
my copy is actually falling apart I've
been reading it so much yes
judge king who do we have we have
training
you me and we have judge Ashley on forms
I know you're running short of time so
maybe well that's my fault and we only
have we meet next at one o'clock for
things so I'm willing to stay past well
why don't judge as we talk about the
phones that shouldn't take too long and
then we'll see where we are okay
and do you have a 91a answer for me in
terms of a few of us from Judiciary the
Judiciary and a few of us decide to uh
work things out nicely before we come
public and announce it I have attorney
Cregan right over here come on
91a issues
good morning chairman uh
you you may or may not know this but the
legislator has not assigned 91a to the
Judiciary so the major operative concern
when you're convening a meeting between
the legislature and the Judiciary is
your rules on
thank you
91a covers the legislature and the
executive branch but it does not cover
the Judiciary we're Bound by part one
article 8 of The Constitution in our
response to public records requests
um so we cannot by definition have a 91a
violation if we meet with you well it's
more accurate to say that the Judiciary
does not have a 91a violation the
legislature is still Bound by its own
rules on convening so if you have a rule
for example for Quorum of members you
would have to open that role would be
observed by your rules I think fewer
than 50 percent of us could have a
wonderful meeting with you at some point
thank you for that appreciate that
thank you chairman Pearson and I
appreciate the opportunity to speak to
you very briefly on the issue of forms
it's the most exciting topic you can
ever think of so they they saved it to a
quarter of 12.
um my name is Susan Ashley I'm the
deputy administrative judge for the
circuit court and I know that this is an
issue that was identified by your
committee to address particularly
user-friendly forms I think
and I'm happy to report that it's good
timing because the judicial branch is
actually on the verge of issuing an RFP
seeking a vendor to assist us with forms
simplification and it's that is tied to
part of the Court's work with the new
there's a fairly new
um entity that has been set up by the
Supreme Court within the administrative
office of the courts it's the office of
access and Community engagement that
that office is working in conjunction
with the Court's access to Justice
Commission you may have all heard of the
access to Justice Commission has been in
place for many years we those of us who
are part of the commission call it a2j
because we always have to have an
acronym for things but the a2j
commission it's it's a it's about 30
something odd folks who are involved
with it members of the courts members of
legal service agencies
attorneys who are often community-minded
and are interested in this and it's
focused on civil matters so it's not a
criminal Focus it's focused on civil
legal issues and making sure that folks
who should be able to have access to the
courts can have that access to the court
so as part of the a2j's work there there
was an application quite some time back
for arpa funds and we actually received
some arpa funds earlier this year for
six different projects and one of those
projects is forms simplification and so
we are at the point at this stage of
issuing an RFP that is looking for a
vendor who will assist the court in the
process of identifying certain forms
that we can make plain language
more plain language than they are at
this point obviously It's tricky because
our forms do sometimes need to contain
legal terms and Concepts that can never
be plain language because they are what
they are you know they've been
legislated to be called whatever they
are but still the use of use of the
forms can be improved for sure
so this effort is going to give it's a
certain finite amount of money of course
that has been given to us through the
arpa funds and it's going to look at
which forms are the highest use forms
that we have and I should just say the
the court system circuit court itself
has upwards of 1100 forms so we're
certainly not going to make all of our
forms user friendly and and why one bite
but it's going to look at which forms we
may be able to improve upon
it's going to have a family lens to it I
can assure you that because that is
where we hear of the most difficulty
with some of our forms again because
these are cases that often do not have
attorneys involved they're going to
identify which ones are most frequently
filled out incorrectly
and that's sometimes they're not filled
out at all which is its own issue but
sometimes they're just complicated and
folks don't understand what they're
supposed to be putting into these forms
so they're going to identify what these
are and and take a crack at improving
them so the vendor would be
looking at those convening folks
convening subject matter experts to
identify those forms and then working on
improving those documents themselves
including instructions for completing
the documents and then they would also
be training Court staff because of
course we're always in the process of
revising forms and potentially creating
new forms if there's a statutory change
or a shift and so it would help us going
forward as well the work is going to be
done we expect over the next
six to nine months the RFP again is just
going out
hopefully sometime this month so that
process will go through its typical
typical process and then the work would
begin in Earnest end of this calendar
year we hope and through the next six
months
simultaneously the court is also and
we've been discussing this for quite
some time you're all aware that some of
our case types are electronically filed
are divorce parenting cases are not
electronically filed but we want to try
to make an impact on those in a way that
might be helpful by utilizing what we
call a guided interview
which is used for instance if you're
filing a guardianship case you're you're
taken through a a guided interview where
it tells you what information it needs
and then it will populate the petition
and it creates the petition for you
this would be a guided interview for our
financial affidavit now you've heard the
judges talk about the financial
affidavit it is
a difficult form to fill out
um it certain requires certain
information sometimes folks don't
exactly understand what that means for
what's being asked so this guided
interview would be a way to have them
input the information it would explain
more what we're looking for and then it
would do certain calculations so they
can put in whatever their income is off
of their paycheck and then it's going to
tell them what their monthly income is
for instance so they don't have to do
the math themselves it we have heard
over and over from self-represented
litigants and from lawyers who do these
cases that this would be an
extraordinary help to all litigants and
family cases if we had this type of a
guided interview so there's some
conversations that we're having to see
how we can advance that technologically
speaking and we're hoping to work on
that as well again over the next many
months to see if we can create something
like that that would be helpful for that
one particular form in our that is
required for all of our parenting and
divorce cases and as judge Lemire said
required to be completed frequently in
those matters the special committee's
subcommittee on forms
um
chaired by representative Greg represent
representative McMahon ball and myself
are also members of this meet next
Tuesday at 1pm my guess is we're just
going to try to identify forms we keep
hearing about I I don't suspect we'll
move towards suggesting litigation or
anything but just being four Friends of
the Court
yeah so that's that's the timeline on
this we'll try to get our work done from
all the things people came in and told
us about and uh absolutely pass them
along which will probably mostly just
underscore what you already know
fair enough well happy to have the input
that you want to provide to us and if we
can provide any further information
happy to provide it and I know you
probably would like to hear from Judge
King so I would like to hear if there
are any questions otherwise I can step
back
uh oh I can get a quick you get a quick
question this is a brief question
thank you Mr chairman uh
is there a is is there some sort of
public participation
now I understand that you will have
you're flagged you have data as to what
forms are complicated uh but in these
processes is there some sort of public
participation there is there is
absolutely going to be public
participation in these but what I was
just speaking about absolutely we want
the input from the public some of it
comes through the a2j commission members
who work closely with various members so
it filters up through them but also one
input from folks who are using these
forms testing and saying is this helpful
and is this the right language to use
and also part of this I didn't get into
it but it's also going to be an ADA
accessibility issue as well so we want
to make sure that their the forms are
accessible to everybody who needs them
right thank you how would my friends in
the back row who would like to be part
of this or in their networks of people
some of whom would like to be part of
this uh discover how they can have their
voices heard
we can provide information to you if
that's helpful to you as to how they can
get input
on these forms issues I can do that
afterwards good okay
okay thank you because I know they will
want to do this great
thank you very much thank you
um judge king are you going to be
meeting with us at one about training I
am then we can have anybody else who
wants to testify
um before that go now in case we run out
of time
and then we re-adjourn it one so anyone
I mean I think we're I think the group
that came with me we're pretty much done
except for the fourth topic of training
which we'll do at one o'clock okay so
there's no need for you to do it twice
okay unless you think you'd like a dry
run
we need training believe me no I'm happy
to do how whatever the committee wants
to do I was prepared to just sort of
give a thumbnail sketch of training but
I'm happy to do that at one o'clock and
give everybody extra 10 minutes that'll
give us a little bit of lunch time but
before everybody goes just remember
those who we've asked if you can provide
us the contact information you're
allowed us to have would appreciate that
also
um we uh identified four different areas
from all the documents that came to us
all the research that was done all the
people testifying we identified four
different areas and we've covered them
today we'll be having our subcommittee
meetings of the special committee and
um
see what happens my guess is that in
some if not all it will be we will have
recommendations
or we would like to schedule a minority
of us to meet with you in in ways that
are appropriate to 91a of the house
there may be a case or so where we would
come up with an LSR and see if it'll
turn into a bill into a law we have been
granted the right even though the
deadline was three weeks ago for house
file bills we as a special committee
have been given a deadline to early
November so if we're going to do that
we have that time framework I've been
told that there may be a few cases where
the Judiciary would actually want us to
make a law or enact a law proposal thank
you proposal law because that would be
helpful to you and if that's the case we
would like to cooperate with that my
guess is once we're done with these four
areas we're going to be taking a look at
a few other areas and I understand that
there's been some conversation amongst
some of the special committee members to
see do we need to have some more
subcommittees and look at other issues
or is our work done and then we file our
final report I think that's still to be
determined going forward if it is
determined that there's one or two other
items we've got November and December
minus holiday periods to have a hearing
and a subcommittee discussion on that so
that's where I think we're going anyone
else from up here then I get to use this
because incrementally I'm being moved to
the law thing from the we're done
there
thank you
very much
in front of them
good afternoon the time being
um one o'clock on October 3rd
um I'm going to call to order the
subcommittee
on the special committee on Family Court
which is looking at judicial training
education
supervision
and accountability these are issues that
came up in the series of hearings that
we've had up until now and
um we are quite honored
to recognize
judge king who is going to
tell us a little bit more about
this area judge king thank you so much
for spending so much time with us today
we know you don't have enough time to do
your job and here we are
taking you away from your job thank you
guys it's an honor to be here I'm David
King I'm the administrative judge of the
circuit court and truly this
is a topic that's very important to me
it's probably one of the more
challenging aspects of my job as an
administrative judge with 60
or so judicial officers with I would say
pretty constant turnover
um
so I've kind of broken it into three
components in terms of training so
component one would be the brand new
judges that come to us and then our
ongoing regular judicial training for
our existing judges and then what I call
for lack of a better term specialty
training and the example I'll use is the
probate division where I'm literally the
only judge left in New Hampshire that
was appointed to the probate court and
we've had some judges with probate
experience who have been doing the
probate work but three of them are
retiring one just retired judge Weaver
two more shortly thereafter and we don't
have the bench
um so I am recruiting existing
experienced judges into the probate
Division and we're putting together a
plan that's my next major project so
that those are kind of the three buckets
and I think
it's in I know you understand this but
it's important to just consider that we
don't choose
judges
um
there's no process
for us to vet Canada executive
Branch that's the way it should be
that's the Constitution but I trying to
think of an analogy a fewer a general
contractor and you build houses and you
didn't hire independent Subs you did
everything and you needed
a Mason and somebody else was doing the
hiring for you and they gave you a bunch
of roofers
you still have to take the roofers but
you have to figure out how to teach the
masonry and you know in a fairly short
time get them into the rotation so that
you can build a complete house we have
to build a complete house in in the
circuit court so as a result we get
judges with a variety of backgrounds
that Governors have done an excellent
job over the years of giving us good
candidates but if we're in a point in
time when we need a lot of family
division judges and we get three or four
prosecutors in a row who are great
lawyers and know the criminal stuff
inside out we still have to teach them
the Family Division because that's our
need at the time
um
probate's another area that's really
specialized it's a it's the only area in
the judicial branch it's actually
growing our criminal numbers are down
our civil numbers are down but New
Hampshire is a growing a graying State
and so our Estates and our guardianships
numbers are going up we need more
probate probate expertise
since we created the Circuit Court in
hard to believe but we've onboarded more
than 50 new judges
I'm the only judge left
full-time judge left it was on the bench
when we created the Circuit Court
my colleagues have all left me there
were 45 full-time judges in marital
Masters and I'm literally the only one
left which I guess tells you that we've
learned a lot about training over the
last 12 years
um we currently as I mentioned this
morning have 13 judicial officers I
can't call them judges because under the
Constitution they're not judges anymore
but 13 judicial officers who are
currently hearing cases who are over the
age of 70. one of them I won't tell you
his age but he's been constitutionally
retired for 10 years
and he regularly takes cases in landlord
tenant and small claims he knows how to
run a docket he's pretty efficient he
does a great job and we use him because
he's good and because we we need all the
days that he can give us and just to put
it in perspective Governor sununu has
appointed 35 judges to the Circuit Court
since he's been Governor so a lot of
turnover we also have a judge recently
appointed whose retirement date is 2057
2057. when I swore him in I said I'll be
dead when you retire which isn't really
funny but it's the truth I mean he's and
if you change the concept if the
Constitution changes
um to 75 he'll his retirement date will
be 2062.
for sure I'll be dead then
um even if I'm really lucky and make it
to my late 90s I think Bob Lynn if this
passes can serve for three weeks
yeah oh I'm sorry and I didn't ask your
permission excuse me
the training of new judges is governed
by a Supreme Court rule 55 we do it
in-house by and large we rely on our
administrators with our five
administrators in the Circuit Court
they're all attorneys we have
authorization for three staff attorneys
we have a newly vacant position as of
today so we actually have two staff
attorneys in the seats we don't have
legally trained clerks our clerks with
two exceptions are not lawyers
so it's the
administrative judges the administrators
the staff attorneys and then judges like
judge Lemire who come in and do case
specific training for new judges
because we don't have law Clerks
we've had to find a different way to
provide that service which is also a big
part of our training so for example we
have a list serve that's very active
that all of the judges and the staff
attorneys are on where a judge can say
hey I've got a landlord tenant case with
this nuance
uh
anybody can anybody help me and you know
an experienced judge usually within a
few minutes we'll see that and provide
an answer or a new judge I'm going on
the bench in five minutes can somebody
call me now and there's always somebody
that sees that and and provides a
Lifeline to the new judges so that's
it's not really training but it is
training in the sense that that's a
resource that's available for new judges
who are constantly learning we're all
constantly learning as far as that goes
um
we have
when covet hit in early March I was
concerned that we were canceling
literally thousands of hearings and
there would be a perception perhaps by
someone from this branch of government
that we had judges who weren't busy so
every judge in the Circuit Court was
given an assignment within a couple of
days
to prepare training materials so judge X
you're doing alimony you're doing
um you know prelimited heirs in the
Probate Court everybody got an
assignment their job was to do a memo on
the substantive law a bench card that
judges could have with a synopsis of
what they needed and a PowerPoint that
we could use for training and I think
there were 50 50 plus assignments and so
kind of within the course of a month we
completely revamped our training
materials that we used to train new
judges and a lot of those include
recorded presentations that we've done
if we bring an expert in if we can find
the money and we can get their
permission to record it let's say it's
on the brain development of children
we've had experts on that
costs money to bring that expert in but
we can record that and put that into the
bank of materials that we have and so
during the course of new judge training
a judge will be assigned to watch that
video and it's a you know it's a way on
sort of the New Hampshire way of doing
things without continually bringing in
speakers that cost money to capture that
because that's sort of a topic that
doesn't change a lot with time the
science behind brain development
so
we cover
everything you know substantively that
we need to cover for training of new
judges
we also take into account the skill set
of the judge that's been appointed so if
we have a prosecutor we know we don't
have to spend a lot of extra time
training on
substantive criminal law but that judge
probably needs a lot more of Judge
lemire's time to learn the family so we
we do not have a one-size-fits-all
training for judges and the training
materials that we have are not static
they're constantly changing it um to
keep up with the law when new folks pass
new laws and we need to do training on
new legislative initiatives then that's
incorporated into the training materials
as well
the training
so I'm happy to answer any questions
about onboarding new judges we have
three in the pipeline right now we have
judge Tanya sponey who was sworn in last
Friday
she has a pretty
wide background she's done quite a bit
of probate she's done a lot of family a
little bit of criminal and some abuse
neglect so she's
got a good background which is kind of
unusual today we have judge Dorothy
Walsh who I'm going to swear in Thursday
morning she's a prosecutor for
Manchester she's done a lot of domestic
violence prosecutors so she's kind of an
expert on DV
and then Elizabeth Payne Betsy Payne is
a was a former that was the domestic
violence expert in in our operation for
20 years I think the first round of
domestic violence protocol she was the
primary author her dad was Bill Payne he
was the county attorney in Carroll
County for years and then became the
Conway district court judge so she's
she's going to be able to wear her dad's
robe if she's confirmed so she comes
with she now works for Casa as a staff
attorney she's been with him for a
number of years so she knows the abuse
neglect
very well and she knows the domestic
violence so when we put those three
together in one class there's a lot of
cross training that we can do just using
the new judges to sort of educate each
other during the course of the training
too
um
question I hope we're not breaking your
train of thought
um when uh the document that you sent us
said that um
uh newly appointed Circuit Court judges
received six weeks of training is that
full-time yes
and that's the ideal situation and
that's hopefully when we the governor's
been great working with us most of the
time these three judges are coming in
like staggered over a period of time and
so
ideally it's six weeks start to finish
and that's all training five days a week
for six weeks it's a combination of
out our uh administrative office so sort
of if you want to use the word classroom
training it's self-study it's mock
trials that we actually have scripts and
we do we you know we teach them the
trial of work it's time in the domestic
violence registry so they learn what
happens when they issue an order where
it goes how it's processed we put them
in the information center for a half a
day just so they can hear the phone
calls coming in because I think that's
instructive about
issues that litigants are struggling
with so that they can sort of have that
in their mind when they're on the bench
it's a lot of shadowing with experienced
judges
and we've debriefed every class if you
will over the last several years and
we've learned that
what we've been told is that the best
way to teach the substantive law is to
have the new judge go to let's say a
landlord tenant session where they're
going to see a whole half day of
landlord tenant hearings
and then the next day we give them the
nuts and bolts substantive law on
landlord tenant we used to do it the
other way around and for whatever reason
it works best when they watch the
hearings and then they get the
substantive loss so we that's all built
into the into the schedule and who
who organizes that
do you have
um a training coordinator we do not it's
a combination of
me
judge Ashley and Heather kulp who's our
senior administrator
um
the staff attorneys are involved but it
changes because
people come and go and
it's it's who has the time
at the moment when a judge gets
appointed again we don't we have no
control over timing of Judges we'll take
them anytime we can get them but
um we don't have any control over that
so
that's certainly something I'd love to
talk about
thank you chair for taking my question
thank you for uh
coming so I wanted to ask
um I guess a multi-part question so you
had stated that the six weeks full-time
would be an ideal situation but I know
that we're time constrained here so
we're not necessarily currently in an
ideal situation so I guess my question
would be how often are we actually doing
the six weeks of training verse how
often are we having to start the judges
sooner because we just we need them to
hear cases and we don't the time isn't
there for us to do that
oh sorry didn't know that
um
I would say I'm going to say 50 50 just
to pull in that's not scientific but I
would say half the time we have a
big enough Group which I would say is
kind of three to make it work the best
to just run it start to finish
we will get the six weeks in one way or
another
but it won't be six continuous weeks
with all three judges at the same time
if that makes sense that nobody gets
shortchanged on what they get we
we might skip something for example we
haven't done uh training on probate
substantive law for a while because it's
a very specialized area of the law and
the judges that do it do a lot of it and
now we're forced to do it because we
don't have the probate division judges
available and the plan for that
um just to share my thoughts
uh since like I said I'm it and we also
we've also had some very long standing
uh one person who was with us for almost
40 years who's been in the probate
division forever retiring so a lot of
our experienced probate staff are
leaving so it's a dual challenge it's
recruiting staff to the probate Division
and judges and so I've
have a recent uh
30-year Deputy clerk who was a deputy
probate register back in the day and has
a extensive knowledge of probate law she
is going to be my partner in this
Recruitment and training effort of
judges and staff and we're going to do
it together meaning we'll be training
staff and judges at the same time on
probate issues and the plan is because
it's going to be involving judges who
are on the bench and have dockets it'll
be 12 to 1 we'll do it virtually and
we'll just pick a topic common law
spouse print admitted heirs just
we'll have materials training materials
it will do the an oral substantive
training and hopefully we're going to
gather some steam and we're going to
start that after the first of the year
try to develop the talent on both sides
of the of the operation
thank you um one other question so you
had mentioned Supreme Court rule 55
governs the new judge training
it actually governs all judge training
so it's not only the new judges but it's
the ongoing training requirement for all
judges okay because I was seeing I saw
continuing ad was under rule 45 but I
wasn't seeing maybe that's the rule that
you're mentioning I I just want to make
sure that I'm looking at the at the
correct thing I see rule 45 is
continuing judicial education and what's
55 something totally different that I
think Alex has about the public
um
we don't have a 65 it only goes to 50 to
uh 62.
um 55 is
public protection fund okay I'd like to
move to amend my
rule to it sounds like it's 45 is doing
okay so it's they're covered under both
the continuing and the new judge is they
both prescribe to this rule 45 correct
thank you and that rule has been changed
in the past few years it used to be that
there was a rule that all new Superior
Court judges had to attend an
out-of-state General jurisdiction
training within
X number of months or years from
appointment and
and the district courts and the probate
courts I mean when I was I was sworn in
and
in February of 1990 and I had a I had I
went to court the next day in the my new
court the Cross County Probate Court and
the register of probe gave me my docket
on a yellow pad and she there was a coat
rack with a robe on it and that was my
training she said this this is the robe
and here's your doc and have a nice day
and I think we've come a long way from
that
through the evolution of the circuit
court because I at least all I had to
know is the probate right I didn't have
to know everything and now with the
Circuit Court when you're appointed to
the Circuit Court under 490f there's a
presumption that you're able to do
whatever we do and the obligation is on
me I think to make sure that judges have
the training before I send them into the
Family Division to do a marital docket I
have to make sure they have the skills
that they need and that the confidence
that they need to be able to handle
those cases and those are the ones
they're most terrified of
the new prosecutors when I say welcome
to the Circuit Court and the Family
Division they
take a deep breath because they know
that with that comes the cases we've
talked about this morning The JCC
complaints that are virtually a
guarantee that come with the territory
and you know the just the
the nature of those cases are they're
difficult cases but everybody gets a
share that's just the the way we work it
in um
judge in
your training the initial training
um
and you're saying that these new judges
will be picking up some cases most
likely before they have finished
certainly their six weeks of
initial training
does that training involve
um
having an experienced either judge or
Clerk of what you have none
um or some Court employee in the
courtroom with a brand new judge to both
be there if perhaps for Council but more
significantly to be there for
evaluation and subsequent
communication yes for sure and what we
we have 34 Court locations some are
pretty small but we have a lot of
multi-judge Courts and we
always Endeavor to put the new judges
for at least their first year into a
courthouse where there are other
experienced judges in the next Chambers
because that's they get constant
feedback during the training process the
mentor judges the experienced judges
will have a judge assigned to them and
typically the way they do it is it's
watch one do one so they'll do a hearing
a lot of the judges are comfortable with
just having the two judges up at the
bench and they'll explain to the parties
what's going on so let's say judge Leary
and Nashua who's been doing this forever
will do a hearing or some hearings and
then the new judge will sit we'll move
over to that chair and judge Leary will
sit beside him or her
and watch and give feedback and
sometimes sit in the back of the
courtroom for a for a few days and watch
and observe and give feedback
um
that's all part of the onboarding new
judge process and we like I said we do
even before we send them to a courthouse
we do mock hearings
in DV cases in landlord tenant cases
just so they can sort of get the Cadence
of a hearing
most of the judges that come to us have
trial experience which is one of the
most important attributes I think
regardless of what type of law you
practice so you know the rules of
evidence you know how cases proceed you
know how to move a case along you know
when somebody's maybe taking too long
and you can with experience push them
along a bit
the judges that have not been in a
courtroom are the ones that would be the
most difficult to train but I don't
can't recall having one of those for a
long time
on your court I can think of at least
one chord where
there is
a member of the judicial branch who I
believe had no
court experience before but we don't
have to discuss that in any detail right
now
well I was appointed by Judd Greg
and
he
appointed one of his legal counsel who
called me after I've been appointed and
said Judd wants to put me on the
Superior Court I've never been in a
courtroom I don't know what to do and I
said I'd take the position and he turned
out to be a very good Superior Court
Judge he had literally never been in a
quorum he was a real estate lawyer for
not a long period of time and he was a
great Superior Court Judge he's long
since retired but it is possible
but you really have to study those Rules
of Evidence and really get up to speed
so they have the confidence of the
people that appear in front of you too
because I think people were skeptical
but
we can train anybody if we are given the
time and the resources to do it
but I think your point might be that
you're not given currently either the
time or the resources to do
well I don't want to put words in your
mouth my understanding is that you have
indicated you could do a better job if
you had more time and more resources is
that correct absolutely we can always do
a better job and I think the the
resource
um the the resources that we have are
the limitation in the number of you know
days that we can put in this and if we
had most most courts I think have a
training person that's their job that
they do judicial and staff training and
I think the Chief Justice would like to
move in that direction I think that's
reflected I didn't see the final version
of the memo but I think in the
suggestion section
yeah I see yes we haven't gotten to that
yet okay but absolutely we could use
more resources to train new judges and
to get back to I think a question that
representative gutab asked about what do
we do with the judges that are sort of
half trained there are some core things
that we do at the front end with every
new judge the first day obviously we get
them fixed up with HR they get their I.T
you know resources their computer their
laptop those kinds of basic things
they spend at least a half day with me
just pouring through the Judicial Code
of Conduct I think that's
the very first thing we need to talk
about when we go through it section by
section and as you can imagine over the
last 30 plus years I have
anecdotal stories about pretty much
every section of the code where things
have or could go wrong and I share those
with the new judges
we talk a lot about procedural fairness
we do a lot of training around just how
to treat people
that come in front of you
there's a lot of research that's been
done peer-reviewed research that
the satisfaction of litigants depends
more on how they were treated than the
result in the case so somebody can lose
a case and say you know what the judge
treated me fairly I'm good with that
people can win the case and think the
Judge is a real jerk so we really want
people to feel like they got a fair day
in court and that they've been treated
right and so we spent a lot of time on
that
and then if we have some judges that
know and I'll just just give you a
specific example when we've had some
judges that are that haven't had all of
the substantive training but they've got
the basic trial skills and the
the basics of how to be a judge because
it is a different skill set when you get
on the other side of the bench for sure
and what we're going to do that this
year the judge the new judges that are
coming on board
we knew there would be delays so we
didn't build them into a schedule we're
behind on our small claims trials your
constituents are probably telling you
that because we're still catching up
from covid we're going to do small
claims blitzes around the state with
these new judges
just going to go in and you know for a
week you're going to hear small claims
cases one after another after another
we're going to try to Chisel that
backlog down
in the bigger courts where those dockets
can be full day multi-day dockets
um so that's our plan that and we've
done that before with success
um I think I know but I'd rather be sure
what is the dividing line on small
claims now that's ten thousand dollars
and between small claims and civil cases
that's about 20 000 cases a year so it's
a pretty good slug of business
thank you do you want to go on with your
initial presentation I I mean I think
I've kind of wandered around a bit I was
going to touch on
the second bucket which is the ongoing
training for existing judges we have
five training days a year
um and I'll call it it's mandatory that
judges go
we're fortunate enough to have some
retired judges
um like judge Spath who's not
constitutionally retired retired so she
will do
all of the arraignments for the whole
state so that judges can be freed up to
go we have a judge who will be doing
warrants for the day and then every
judge in the state gets emergencies
every day the judges have to bring their
laptops to training and they have to be
available for the DV the ex party
parenting the child placement so there
we take breaks during the day so they
can check their laptops and issue
emergency orders but
it's five solid days of training our
next one is Friday
and we are fortunate enough to have some
money from the bar Foundation which is a
dedicated fund we have judge Sutton I
think I may have mentioned that in the
materials
um
from the sixth Circuit Court of Appeals
coming to do a talk on
the U.S Constitution versus the New
Hampshire Constitution and how they
interact and I think it will be a really
good program
and then we're doing training at that
event on the new protocols and abuse
neglect cases
so it's a smattering of trainings you
know of all the case types that we cover
spread out over the year and judges can
tell us what what they need
um
we try to send all of our new judges
within the first year or two to a
National week-long Domestic Violence
program that's put on by the ncj fcj the
National Council of juvenile and Family
Court judges
and to also an ncj fcj program on abuse
neglect cases we got way behind
during the covid years because we had 20
judges that had come on the bench that
didn't have that training
so what we did last summer is we brought
the NC jfcj judges to New Hampshire and
we did a multi-day program here
mandatory for the 22 new judges and then
Friday was a regular judicial education
day for us and all judges went to the
third day of that it was a it was a
great program
so right now all of the judges have had
the National Training except the three
new ones that are coming in
other points you want to share with us
right now
you know
well I just think in terms of the tools
just which I think does dovetail with
education in addition to the listserve
the
um the training materials we have an
orders bank that is loaded with orders
that judges have written on all case
type so you know for me I've submitted
orders in the probate World on undue
influence incapacity cases in the trust
World
um you know suppression issues in
criminal cases anything that's got
that's a well-written order and we we
kind of vet them go into the orders bank
and they're searchable by topic they're
searchable by you can do a word search
so that's really helpful the list serve
is archived by the staff attorneys
because the same questions tend to come
up
so rather than reinvent the wheel we and
we have a you know broken down by
landlord tenant whatever the different
case types are so people can go search
there all of the new Supreme Court
decisions that come down are summarized
and archived in
there and anytime that a staff attorney
writes a memo on a substantive issue
that goes into a Memo's bank and those
are searchable
um by case type so that's how we've made
up for not having law Clerks
that's kind of
um a
virtual law clerk if you will and the
staff attorneys one of the staff
attorney's responsibilities is to make
sure that those stay current so if
there's a memo that's outdated because
the legislature's changed the law or the
Supreme Court's changed the law then we
remove the no longer relevant materials
and we try to keep it updated
thank you madam chair and thank you
judge no law Kirk clerk says this always
been the case
yes is there a reason
well it's resource is the reason but the
historically pre-circuit Court we had
the district court at one time there
were a hundred district court judges
around the state they were very mostly
part-time judges and they just kind of
did their own thing and then the probate
judges
there were 10 of us most we were all
part-time when I was appointed in 1990
all the probate judges were part-time
the probate court was the first court to
get a staff attorney uh non-superior
Supreme Court
which I thought was pretty clever at the
time I've had several and many have
become many of my staff attorneys have
become judges
but
the superior court has always had law
clerks and the Supreme Courts always had
law clerks the Supreme Court has 11 law
clerks Superior Court has I think 15 or
16 law clerks so it's about one law
clerk for every judge and a half
in the Superior Court Supreme Court
judges all have two and the chief
justice has three
it's certainly I hear about it all the
time from the Circuit Court judges that
it would be a huge help
um but again we we do what we can with
what we have thank you thank you um kind
of like those old TV shows I used to
watch in the 50s where the the judge
rolled into town and he was a Savvy old
coot and he knew the law and he knew his
people and he didn't need a locker he
was one to himself I'm kind of hearing
New Hampshire in a more Northeastern way
was a bunch of uh small town part-time
judges doing things and it worked for
sure the state grew it was a it was a
lot simpler back then too I think the
issues were simpler and the marital
cases move much more quickly we didn't
have a trust code so we we didn't have
trust litigation which is what I do when
I'm not doing the administrative judge
work I do the complex trust docket and
you know for years judges lawyers have
said
for many years
you need to trust you know avoid probate
get a trust and that's where all the
litigation is that the litigation is in
the trust world and
those cases are I started a case last
week it was supposed to be two days and
on the first day of trial they said we
need three more we haven't even started
the case yet
those are multi-day trials some involved
in New Hampshire there's a lot of money
in New Hampshire
a lot of money in New Hampshire had
cases with multi-millions of dollars the
tamposia's case is the most famous one
but that was a 29 day bench trial in the
Circuit Court
and the legal fees were over six million
dollars so we we do some big cases
which is why we need to train up some
more probate judges
um because somebody's going to take my
place when you I go on to greener
pastures
a follow-up on my follow-up I hear ads
on WBZ Radio all the time don't lose
your assets to a nursing home you need
to have a trust and I know a number of
people who say well gosh does that mean
a simple will isn't good enough anymore
you know
so are you saying trusts are more
complicated than I might have led to
believe there are certainly good reasons
to have trusts okay
um but it shouldn't be a will substitute
in every case when people have modest
assets and
no you know they typically you get to
trust and then you don't fund the trust
or you put some of your assets in the
trust but you always forget something so
now you have an estate open and you have
a trust open at the same time so it
doesn't it doesn't make my life simpler
as a probate division judge just because
you have a trust unless you completely
do avoid probate
thank you and all this time I thought
this was a device by the
members of of the bar not the bench to
be able to generate business am I wrong
about that you don't have to answer that
well I think let me just simply say this
I think you can charge more to create a
trust than you can a simple will perhaps
thank you yes and the kiss principle I
think always works
um
you have uh if I'm if I'm
if you are where I think you are and we
go to the suggestions section
you talk about a New Hampshire judicial
College
um
you know I'm not necessary
necessarily sure are you you know you
need something
that sounds as highfalutin as uh New
Hampshire judicial College as much as
you might need
a director of training
um
or
a department of training
um
I see that your hope is that it would be
in the 2627 budget which would be
surprisingly as it sounds the next
budget right we're almost ready to start
asking
do you have and I know you don't want to
commit to a particular number but do you
have any sense of
what size
Dollar Wise
that would be to make sense to do it at
all
so I I don't know what the Chief Justice
and I haven't really sat down with
putting pencil to paper but I think the
concept is fairly simple that we would
and I think that whatever we call it is
secondary I think maybe call I don't
know if college is too fancy a word but
I think the concept is we have a
dedicated training person
who is responsible for maintaining the
training materials for the two trial
courts for putting together what what
are now our five programs a year because
we obviously do all of that ourselves
and that's pretty time consuming
for bringing in
experts from the outside because it's
more I think it's more cost effective
especially with airfare and travel and
everything that goes with it it's it's
expensive to send even three judges to
Reno for a week
why don't we bring the resources here
and do in-house trainings but that takes
a lot of time too so I think the concept
would be this person would manage
everything having to do with training
for judges and probably some of the
staff training
using in-house resources but also using
exterior resources whether it's sending
judges to programs or bringing programs
here I don't see it as a big
um
a big staff
effort at least that's would be my
vision I think it would be the New
Hampshire way but it would be
someone who's dedicated to doing that so
that this consistency and predictability
in in terms of timing and making sure
that new judges get what they need when
they come on board
maybe I'm being influenced by the fact
that we're sitting in the very room
where you would have to defend the
budget to division one
if you were given a pot of money
whatever the size is we don't have to
talk about that now do you think it
would be more help
to the effective operation
of the Court
to have clerks and support staff
or to have a significantly enhanced
training operation
I thought that would be an easy question
for you I've sat in the seat for a lot
of budget Cycles I've never left with a
pot of money but
um I think well now wait a minute wait
wait wait wait oh I've done very well
I'm not being I'm being facetious I just
haven't had that pot of money I've been
yeah no I mean I'm going to have chair
leishman talk to you about this so be
careful no we did I'm very grateful for
the last budget cycle for sure we were
we're very grateful we got pretty much
what we asked for so I I didn't mean to
be flipping about it
but I think to answer your question
Madam chairman I think
uh the availability of law clerks would
be a huge Improvement
for the Circuit Court in terms of
as I said this morning the quality of
the orders and the timeliness of the
odors I think would both go up and I
I've used this I'll use this as a simple
example one of our judges
posted an order and this was this goes
back a number of years but it was a
relatively new judge who was writing an
order on a fourth amendment search with
a motor vehicle misdemeanor okay but
it's still somebody could go to jail for
and it was a it was a half pager with
one case
uh and just wanted to get some feedback
and the law was I think right and there
were enough facts to substantiate it but
in the spirit court that might have been
a six or seven page order
you know that a law clerk would have
researched and written and
so to the extent we get criticized about
our orders it's part of it's a time
crunch we've and we tell the new judges
this you're not
writing orders
for you know
the Supreme Court every time it's more
important to get the orders out and we
see that in judicial evaluations the
judges that
take more time to write longer orders
often get criticized by the lawyers at
least saying you know what I'd I'd
rather get a short order
timely than a six-page order that you
know that we have to wait two months for
and I I get that
um and every judge is different the
judges that stay off the overdue orders
list are the ones that have figured out
how to write a quicker order and get it
out rather than make sure that every
single comma is in the right place and
um every piece of punctuation is perfect
I'd like to go to oh I'm sorry I see
that you have something you want to say
first go on
I just wanted to follow on to that I
mean I guess
what if it could be
a tiny bit of both and that you could
get your
training coordinator instead of a
college a whole college and then you
could
perhaps get some law clerks would that
perhaps be
a better Direction because then if
you've got the coordinator to to put
through
you know to to organize all the training
for you but then you've got some clerks
that can help with writing orders
because we know that judges are
currently writing orders from home and
they don't really have anybody to and
especially in the Pro Se family court
cases to kind of go through and help
flag hey these are really important
pieces that you want to make sure you
look at in this file what do you sounds
like a a good compromise to me
I think the fact that I think some of
what we're doing here is is doing a
little PR education indicating you do
not propose a New Hampshire
judicial College because that sounds
like it's next thing you know you're
going to build a building with columns
in front so be careful of what you call
it you just want a little New Hampshire
but
um
another component of this which
is of concern to me is what I call and
perhaps not precisely enough
accountability
it's one thing
when a red flag goes up because
something clearly was done that was
inappropriate in terms of whether it's
uh
the legal appropriateness or
Behavior or whatever it happens to be
but that's going to be very few cases
and very few judges what concerns me is
the routine
accountability
knowing day in and day out
that
everything that you do as a judge
is really
um sacred
in a Democratic Society when we if we
believe in this and I happen to one who
does and I think you do too
um so that it's even little things it
might be a question of demeanor do you
realize that you are treating
let me give you an obvious one that you
were treating
um women attorneys in a way that's
different from the way you're treating
male attorneys
um
and it might not affect the outcome of
the case but it affects the public
perception
and
how how do you provide account of
routine accountability
for those things that aren't going to
end up getting someone removed from the
bench
but could make the difference between
a public perception of a careful
well-run judicial system and one that
might not be so well done yeah and
that's a fair and a great question and I
it reminds me of a conversation you and
I had
10 years ago a number of years ago well
I don't know what you can tell me the
year you were chair of house Judiciary
and I made a and it was an issue about
the ratio of women judges to men judges
I just want to well I think of it make
the point that I'm very proud that with
these last three appointments by
Governor sununa will be at 47 women of
our full-time bench will be women on the
Circuit Court which I think is great
um but to the accountability since as I
understand it coming out of the law
schools women are in the majority now is
that I've heard that I've heard I think
it's I think the 37 of the New Hampshire
bar so if we're 10 ahead of that in our
bench I think that's a great sign
um and I'm proud of that but the
accountability is
um hugely important and
first of all New Hampshire is a small
state
um so it's
what we do judicial evaluations every
three years as you know and we were on
that committee together for a number of
years we revamped the
um the survey instrument
um
rarely do I get a Judicial evaluation
when I'm surprised
let me just say that because it's a
small state a lawyer's talk the lawyers
and the self-represented people are not
shy about either emailing me mailing me
calling me when they have an issue and
it's so easy today if I get a call or
someone says you know the judge was rude
to me or the judge did this or that
within a matter of
depending on what staff's available in
the building but usually within an hour
or two I can have the audio from that
hearing on my laptop and I can listen to
it which is the first thing that the
judicial conduct commission does when
they get a complaint they call us we
have a good relationship we send them
the audio either electronically or on a
CD and most of the complaints go away
because no the judge didn't swear at the
person the judge didn't raise their
voice
but we do take that very seriously and
when there are issues
I either pick up the phone or I drive to
the courthouse and have a chat with the
judge that's that's I think an important
part of my job to make sure that those
are nipped in the bud especially with a
new judge that they develop good habits
um
so the judicial
accountability
evaluation process is sort of going on
all the time
in the circuit court and I think the
Superior Court does the same thing
do you wait for a let's use a gentle
term a concern to be raised or are there
retired judges that spot sit in
different
courtrooms
so the the short answer is at this time
I do wait until I hear something we have
going back to when Ed Kelly was the
administrative judge we have had
conversations about using retired judges
to just and I think the new judges would
welcome this frankly
and we experienced judge to just sit in
the courtroom for a day or two make some
notes and then go into Chambers and say
you know I saw this I saw that we we did
an interesting
um program probably 15 or more years ago
and Ned Gordon judge Gordon then was one
of the judges who volunteered just put a
video camera in the back of a courtroom
of a number of courtrooms around the
state including Ned Gordon's courtroom
and then we use those videos at a
training for judges and I'm not going to
pick on Judge Gordon just because he's
not here because he's he would he's
heard this before but he was on the
bench and he had there were two hearings
that came to mind one was the domestic
violence hearing
and when the victim was testifying he
was paying close attention
and when the defendant was testifying he
would he seemed to be not paying as
close attention and the perception to
somebody watching that video was that
judge Gordon wasn't listening to the
other side I know he was
um and then there was another case that
was kind of going on and his head was
down and what he said he was doing was
he was ruling on a stack of warrants
that were on the bench he was listening
but he was sort of multitasking but
again if you're watching the video your
perception is just not listening to
anything I'm saying so that was very
eye-opening for judges uh we should we
should probably try to do more of that
the video cameras are not expensive and
somebody's got to manage it and do it
but it's a pretty good training tool but
ideally we would use retired judges who
we would um
recognize as someone that would be good
at it to go watch new judges and provide
feedback the problem is they're all
sitting for us right now because we need
them
um
but I think that would be a great tool I
think you refer to that as maybe
monitoring a monitor or something
like that yeah if I may we had a
conversation about my role as executive
director of a medical center when we get
students coming in
I'm right on that to see my gosh
today you saw seven people with serious
diagnoses three of whom reminded you of
loved ones how you doing
and if we don't get on that right away
and teach them how to be very present to
the moment but at the end of the day put
it in the drawer and go home and think
of other things you will either become
cold and clinical or you will
self-medicate or something won't work
right for you and therefore your patient
care so I'm very keen on monitoring
um our young young people coming through
us and again just kudos to you I raised
the issue I think I raised it with the
chief maybe with you I'm familiar quite
a bit with post-traumatic stress
disorder in my work with the fire
department and if you have had numbers
of traumatic experiences maybe they
didn't happen to you but they happened
to somebody and you were observing there
will be takeaways and down the road
something will trigger and you may not
make the connection it may be
subconscious but something will trigger
a recollection back to one or more of
those events and you you will act
accordingly and I'm just saying
especially in Family Court where you're
hearing all of these things all day
it may trigger something in the judge's
own life or a loved one of the judges
and so on and I I do encourage you along
the way as you're building your team of
people for supervision and
accountability to have a mental health
person who's familiar with that to help
judges watch for the signs in themselves
as well well and that's a that's a great
comment um with the idea of secondary
trauma not only for judges but for staff
is a real thing and I can think of one
instance specifically I remember that
well the judge a judge calling me on the
weekend and had been managing this abuse
neglect case for a number of months and
the mother was doing great she was in
treatment she was you know recovering
and he felt like he was having a
positive effect on this family and over
the weekend he heard that she had used
again an overdosed and died and he
thought it was his fault you know and he
was very upset
um and you know I was trying to walk him
through and convince him that it wasn't
your fault and and another time I had
someone who works in our dictation
Center all our orders are typed that
judges that use the dictation Center and
the staff person came in was crying and
she had been following this family by
typing orders and all of a sudden she's
typing away and someone died from an
opioid overdose and it was just very
upsetting because she was sort of
through the lens of these court orders
following the life of this family that
looked like everything's going to be
okay and all of a sudden it's not so we
are doing trainings around secondary
trauma for staff and judges but we can
always do more okay thank you
what about I don't know how to work what
about r r for judges who are
handling these
traumatic difficult painful cases is
there any opportunity for a break
in that in terms of the cases that they
are handling or does it become
impossible because you don't have enough
judges no I think we try to rotate
judges and
I if you remember back when we
at Kelly and I testified House Bill 609
our our vision of initially of the
Circuit Court our vision not really know
what we were talking about because it
came to be so quickly was that there
would be these three divisions and you
would be in the Criminal Division for a
rotation a year or two years and then
you go to the Family Division and then
you go to the probate Division and it
sounded good in practice it doesn't work
except in the very largest courts
because all of our medium and small
courts just have have to do everything
but we do take judges off the family
cases for respite from time to time put
them in the Criminal Division
put them in hopefully we'll attract some
to the probate division but there are
Judges like judge Lemire
who is very good at family and that's
what she wants to do and
frankly I haven't tried to talk her out
of it and she takes on some of the more
difficult cases that's just her
wheelhouse she signed up to be a marital
Master knowing the work and we have a
few of those judges that I'm grateful
for
so regarding the having the camera and
giving feedback I visited the Manchester
Court and I realized that there was a
the
security team had a video of the
courtroom that was going on as well as
audio that was going on so I guess in
the courts that do currently have that
going on as part of their security
system would that be something that
perhaps
could be reviewed from time to time just
you know to see if
you know things are being checked into I
guess so the video is bit the video
cameras are video only for security the
audio is the record from the court so to
marry the two up I think I'm not sure
that would work
we the so the cameras that you see in
the lobbies and in the quorums are not
recording audio
so in Manchester they were playing the
audio in the lobby that were one of the
courts that they were watching the
hearing at the same time are you saying
that even though the audio was playing
that it wasn't recording
this recording on the FTR the the for
the record recording equipment in the
room but that's not
a camera that's recording it
contemporaneously so you'd have the
audio outside of the courtroom though
it would be coming through the PA system
that's attached to the microphones but
not
I'm not sure I mean oh it's not recorded
so it was through a PA microphone okay
right the videos are important though if
we have I mean typically security issues
um if something happens in altercation
in the courtroom that's really why those
are there those are the really for
security not for audio video recording
of the hearings so there is no audio on
those video recordings correct thank you
even in the lobbies it's not audio
we want to help I I think you know that
um
I think you know I wouldn't be part of
anything well we didn't want to help
do you have any
specific suggestions
that you would like to make either now
or in another venue at another time
where you see what the legislature
could do to help and because the two
categories they're things where the
legislature might say of course this is
This falls on your Turf but it seems to
us that you might want to try X Y or Z
where we have no authority to pass
legislation nor should we but
representing the citizens of the state
we see some things that maybe you should
look at that's one category
then there's a category of things that
clearly
fall on our side of the line
and
where working with our legislative
colleagues
we might be able to
help you
do even better in delivering Justice
to the citizens of the state and
I think that
I I know a majority and probably
it's all of the people on this special
committee would like
to do that would like to do
what we could do to make it better
now you might not feel ready to do that
right now you might not want to use this
particular
audience to do it but I would like to
very formally from this committee you
know looking at training education
supervision and accountability all of
which I think address the quality
of of the delivery of of Justice
we'd like to know where you who know
this much better than we do
would make some suggestions
so I am grateful for the invitation the
way the branch operates is that we work
with the Supreme Court and we formulate
our asks through that mechanism so I
will certainly and by the way the Chief
Justice I think wanted to come this
morning with the hit oral argument so
um he was aware that we're here today
and I think would have come butt for
that fact so I will
definitely
um get together with him and the
administrative Council and come to you
with
some suggestions I think probably a lot
of which we've already touched on today
in terms of I just hate you know it's
hard to come here and keep asking for
more because you did give us what we
asked for this year we asked for
upgraded labor grades for our staff
for more staff positions and we ask four
more judges and we got that and we're
trying to do it incrementally so we
don't
ask for too much at once
that relates to money and of course as
you and you've heard me say any number
of times when they say it's not the
money you know it's the money
but
um there might be other steps that we
could take
through legislation
um after all we created the court in the
first place
um and we know we know none of those
courts are in the Constitution right
um and so there you know these are
things that we can do
if we chose and I think we would be more
likely to choose if we knew that those
who know the most about the delivery of
Justice could see ways that we could do
this
better
and we would like to do that so it's a
question of working together
and we're happy to do that and the fact
that this committee exists is a concern
to me just because there's a perception
that we could you know that there is a
problem and to that extent I want to be
able to be part of the solution
I think I think that's true I think at
the big we know it's true we see I don't
serve on children and family I serve on
Judiciary
so that it's only by uh observing across
the room that I see the the bills that
come in to Children and Family
um and whether they are
uh
uh justifiable or not whether
the questions that are raised are you
know are verifiable or not is Irrelevant
in the system that we have
any legislator is free to file as many
bills as they choose
and one would hope that these bills
would have been well researched before
they
they found them but that is not a
requirement and in many cases
legislature
files a bill because someone asked him
or her to do so and then drops that bill
on the
committee desk and expects the committee
to
make a gold out of chaff and that's not
the committee's responsibility either
chairman Pearson struggles with this and
it's out of all of that because he wants
to do the right thing and I'll ask that
this committee was formed and
um
I think
we have succeed I hope we've succeeded
in putting many of the concerns in
appropriate perspective
recognizing the pain the distress the
unhappiness in any individual might feel
but also recognizing that that's not
necessarily affecting or reflective of
the entire core
and so what we want to do now is say
okay what can we do working together to
make it better
and so I hope that you will not just
wait
and think that oh well they're sure to
see what needs to be done
because that's as much as we would like
to
we have 800 bills you know
a couple of things number one
um you can say to the Chief Justice that
I certainly forgive him for not being
here because the last three times he and
I were together he gave me a law book
each time and I'm two books behind and
and I just need a little bit more time
myself secondly the etiology of this
committee was that we had some bills
that came to children and family law
that
um let's just say it didn't look like
the judicial system that I know a little
bit about and I spoke to the speaker
about it and he said let's form this
special committee and in part it will
get bipartisan and cross the age span
and freshmen and Veterans and so on all
looking at the different topics and
coming to our conclusions as to what we
think the Judiciary is doing which I
think most of us think it's doing pretty
good but also use the occasion to say
hey let's have a dialogue about how we
can make a good thing better that's this
initial conversation I had with the
speaker that led to this committee being
formed and that's why I'm taking this
and a collaborative and not anticipant
and that one manner you will never hear
me say we can't do things better I know
and I'm open to suggestions and I'm
excited about the opportunity to
collaborate and try to come up with some
solutions that we can that maybe don't
cost money but
that will help the system
so yeah I mean I believe I heard you
talk about two areas that maybe did cost
money and that was the you know judicial
training coordinator and then perhaps
the law clerks and I think and I don't
want to speak for her but I think what
our our Madam chairwoman was also
discussing was there if there's any
policy areas that perhaps if the policy
areas were looked at a bit if they would
if that would enable you to perhaps
improve the quality of Justice that's
that's coming out is there anything
that's kind of tying judges hands where
they're like
hey I don't I really don't think this is
fair but I have to issue this order
because that's the way that it's that's
the way that the statues written so if
there's if you can kind of think about
that in some ways and I do think
you know if we're making some
recommendations out of this committee
and I'd certainly some things are always
about the money and we can't we can't
have an unlimited bucket of money but I
think we do have some leeway for some
things if they're really urgent and we
do need to to do them that
we wouldn't necessarily have to wait
until the next budget if something was
really needed so I just I kind of wanted
to
put that into perspective
I do want to make clear that that last
comment has not been discussed with
chairman Weiler
well actually it has Madam chairwoman
because I see him at least weekly and
the subject of what I want him to do in
the next budget for the Judiciary is an
ongoing conversation it's the next
budget not this but
hahaha
I will say that when we were here for
division one chairman Wallace sat in
that chair and I reminded him that he
was chair of house finance when we
created the circuit court and we made a
lot of promises and I think we kept them
all in terms of the multi-millions of
dollars that we
cut and have continued to save
I feel a little bit responsible I think
we cut too deeply at the time and it's a
lot harder to get things back than it is
to give them up but with that said the
legislature's been very good to us in
the last few budget cycles and so I have
no complaints about that I remember
touring the the telephone Center well as
you hear Chicago and we've taken 5
million calls
and we didn't lose a call during covet
even in that first week we moved people
out with their cell phones and we didn't
drop a call so that's a success story
too that I'm very proud of we have taken
so much of your time today and I feel
really guilty about it because Justice
delayed is Justice denied but is there
anything else that you would like to
share with us now no just my thanks for
all again all of the work that you've
done it's pretty remarkable about you
know how much time you spent over the
course of the last few months listening
to
testimony about the circuit court and I
am supposed to be at another hearing it
too so I'll okay well you don't want to
delay you fashionably late do you need a
note from me to say that it's okay that
you're a little late I might have to
come back to get that but okay you know
you know where to find them
thank you very much thank you
so we're going to okay around the corner